foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do we have any preliminary matters
before we have to turn yes sure
foreign
foreign
thank you good morning ladies and
gentlemen all right let's Witness
good morning your honor um plaintiff
calls Tara Roberts
here on here
Miss Roberts can you hear me
can you hear me Miss Roberts
Mr Roberts
I can see you
excuse me
yeah you can bring them in
see if she's on mute or not
foreign
she's right there
oh
can you hear me Mr Roberts
yes I can okay great can you raise your
right hand for me
do you swear from tell the truth on a
penalty of law
okay thank you ma'am
we can't see her on the big screen
foreign
just do it split screen so we can start
please
all right go ahead and ask your question
go ahead
it's the best we're going to do right
now okay
um
morning would you please state your name
for the record
tarly Roberts
Miss Roberts how do you know Johnny Depp
I manage his island in the Exuma keys in
the Bahamas for the past 15 years
Miss Roberts where do you live
I live on I live on the island and I
have a home in Nassau and in Long Island
Bahamas which I tried to get to as
frequently as possible
can you please describe Mr Depp's
Private Island generally
um my duties on the private island would
be to maintain the
Island the buildings the houses
Logistics not included or limited to
provisioning fuel uh
gas groceries
um just day-to-day operations staff
and kind of like an estate just in the
middle of nowhere
your honor I would like to pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 49 which has
previously been submitted into evidence
okay
um and Mr Gibson if you could play this
and your honor if we could publish this
to the jury
foreign
thank you we can take that down Miss
Roberts do you recognize what is shown
in that video
yes that's Johnny's House on the island
okay thank you
um Mr Gibson can you please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 348.
and this hasn't been submitted into
evidence yet so let's first just play
that for Miss Roberts
Miss Roberts do you recognize what is
shown in that video
yeah that's his house and and uh closet
area
okay
um your honor I'd like to plenty of
moves to admit this into evidence all
right 348 in evidence do you wish to
have it published yes can we please
publish that to the jury
and Mr Gibson once it's published if you
could play that again
and Miss Roberts what is that doorway
with the beads
um that was just shown in that video
that's the entrance to the closet
thank you we can take that down in his
house
Miss Roberts I believe you mentioned
that you manage staff on the island how
many people work with you on the island
myself and and three others is uh Jason
major goes by CJ Stephen Farrow and Rico
major
is this I believe the witness is not
being shown to the jury right now
on their screens
thank you
with us
there you go thank you
Miss Roberts how are you compensated for
your work on the island
I receive a monthly salary
other than this monthly salary what
other sources of income do you have
um I get dividends and rental from
Family Properties and businesses that we
have
since you've been working for Mr Depp
how often have you seen him
on average uh two three times a year
sometimes it was longer more visits
sometimes I didn't see him for a period
of time depending on what his schedule
was or what was happening on the island
and how would you describe your
interactions with Mr debt
the island was a very family atmosphere
dinners together he was very social
funny humorous very kind with all of us
and very very outgoing I enjoyed working
with them before him
when you first started working on Mr
Depp's Island who would come down to the
island
um at the beginning it was um Vanessa
and the children objection relevance
right hold on a minute man I'm objection
relevance
uh it goes to
um just miss Robert's knowledge of who
came down to the island to move forward
next question okay
um
uh Miss Roberts
um when well Mr Roberts are you aware if
Mr Depp brought or how often did Mr Depp
bring guests with him to the island
um
he had uh
guess he would bring Amber and Amber
with her friends and also I had on one
of the occasions I had Paul Bettany and
his wife and his children here on on one
of the trips and when did the betnese
come down to the island
um sometime in the summer of July 2013.
what happened when the betnes came down
um it was a normal trip I just I we had
an incident where I was asked to
um
have Amber leave the island I scheduled
a flight for her to leave to go to
Florida that morning and then that
afternoon I was told to bring her back
and I arranged for a flight for her to
come back that afternoon to the island
when did you first meet Miss heard
I believe it was shortly after they
started dating
what was your impression of Miss heard
when you first met her
objection oh they're very much in love
relevance
okay go ahead next question
I
I think Miss bardahof has brought her
objection yes go ahead okay so uh Miss
Roberts you can answer what was your
first what was your impression of Miss
heard when you first met her
cleaned up they took care of each other
they were a very happy couple
when if at all did that change
um with each visit it it changed um
more of um it was more not uh like an
island life anymore it was more of um
wines and and more more requests uh
simple things toiletries uh to have
things here in place before
um they came or she came as well
um so it you know luggage changed got
more and more luggage we I mean just
things evolved in kind of mushroomed um
mushroomed a bit
how often would you see misheard on the
island when she was in a relationship
with Mr Depp
on average every day I'm taking meals
cleaning houses
um sometimes more
and how often would miss heard come down
to the island
um
I think probably the same two or three
times a year
sometimes three times with their friends
and family and and Johnny
during your interactions with Miss heard
what if any changes Did You observe of
misheard
um
the the
taking care of the cooking the meals we
had we then had a chef come to cook
um it was more of um it was more of a
formal Island
um with chefs and housekeepers and
things like that
um
changed
um and uh
pretty much that
Miss Roberts were you on the island in
August 2014 for Mr Depp's detox
yes I was
who else was on the island
um I flew to Nassau and met um
Johnny Amber and Deb I brought them flew
them back to the island and then a
couple of
um Miss Roberts I believe you froze
there for a second I heard you say
Johnny Amber and Deb and then you were
cut off for a second
a couple of days into a couple days
later Dr Kipper arrived
um what do you recall about that time
that Mr Depp came down to the island in
August 2014.
here for extended period of time at
least a month or longer
um and so we provisioned for a month for
for the trip
um and after about a week or two they
left
where was Mr Depp staying for the detox
in in his house
is that the same house that was just
shown in those videos earlier
yes it was
how often would you see Mr Depp when he
was on the island for the detox
um
I was every day but not
um face to face
um just from delivering um some
replenishing the house delivering
supplies Waters and things like that
Linens and changing things out so
glimpsing him not not a conversation as
it used to be
how was Mr Depp when you saw him
uh he was always asleep on the couch
while miss heard was on the island for
the detox what if any injuries Did You
observe on this herd
I didn't I didn't see anything
after Mr dappen misheard left the island
what happened next
we would go
and break it down empty out the
refrigerators change the Linens collect
the laundry straighten house back up
again
after they left
um what if any property damage did You
observe
there wasn't any
Miss Roberts to what extent were you
involved in Mr Depp and Mrs heard's
wedding in February 2015 on the island
um
pretty much all aspects of it Logistics
work permits getting things set up onto
the island to the Ireland staff
Provisions
um
building of the the tens and and
organizing transportation of guests to
and from the island
when did you first hear that Mr Depp and
misheard were getting married on the
island
irrelevance when she heard I can move on
okay next question
um what Communications if any did you
have with misheard about the wedding
um I
we were given um
the information on a schedule
to better help me schedule and the
provisioning of what would be on the
island Beverages and food and things
like that we were given a schedule for
daily
um things we're going to uh
happen each day
what time Foods were when people were
coming in how many people would be at
meals just so we I had a better idea of
planning of what was happening it was
detailed um was what was happening each
day
um
on
and then it was uh the rehearsal night
and there would be you know we had
scheduled it would be dinner dancing
drugs music and then the wedding we were
very um
conscious about doing the wedding the
next day we were doing the wedding
um the ceremony and we were specific on
time privacy was very important
um we were very careful of people taking
pictures I think everybody was given um
disposable cameras and ask not to take
pictures
um I was concerned about that also but
we were doing the ceremony at Sunset so
there really wouldn't be uh issue with
um
what Paparazzi people and things like
that and
um shortly when the ceremony was about
to happen it actually happened earlier
than it was scheduled the bridal party
and Amber showed up early and we were
still scrambling for flowers and setting
up and getting Beverages and um
snacks down there and there was a plane
circling overhead and it was just kept
on circling and circling and taking
pictures and the ceremony proceeded
earlier than
um was scheduled
Did You observe Mr dap drinking alcohol
at the wedding objection lady
all right I'll sustain the objection
okay
um
Miss Roberts as part of the provisioning
for the wedding did you
um
order alcohol for the wedding objection
leading stained okay
Miss Roberts what did you order for the
wedding in February 2015
um I was I was given a list of uh food
um I was given a list of beverages for
wines Champagnes I was asked to
um have Dr Pepper and sugar-free Red
Bull here because at that time that was
what Mr Depp or Johnny was drinking was
Dr Pepper and sugar-free Red Bull
okay
um Did You observe miss her drinking
alcohol at the wedding
objection leading sustained
who did You observe drinking alcohol at
the wedding
um pretty much everybody was was
drinking and doing shots and celebrating
it was it was a party
uh Miss Roberts I'd like to discuss with
you when Mr Depp and misheard were on
the island in December 2015. who came
down to the island with them
um I flew to Nassau
um to meet them which is what I normally
do
um I meet
himself Johnny and and whoever comes to
the island I fly to Nassau to meet them
just to make sure that the transition is
smooth with customs and immigration so I
flew to Nassau and I met um
Johnny Amber his children and a friend
of their of the children and
um load the luggage onto the Caravan
plane and we boarded the plane and and
came to the island
um and a couple days into the trip
um Alice and
Greg analysis three children and a nanny
came to the island as well
who are Alice and Gregg
Alice is a
clothes designer and Greg was her
partner and I believe he's a
photographer
when did you first interact with Miss
heard when she came to the island in
December 2015.
I'm at the airport when I flew to Nassau
to meet to meet everybody usually when
they come down off the plane you know
there's hugs and kisses and chatting for
a couple minutes while the luggage is
transferred
how close were you to miss heard
close hug close hug kiss
he talked same
so face to face cheek to cheek
what if any makeup Did You observe Miss
heard wearing when you first interacted
with her
I don't recall
uh she was or was not wearing makeup
um she she if she wore makeup it was
very natural
um I I don't think often she wore makeup
on the island
um I I don't recall her wearing makeup
what if any injuries did you notice on
misheard
I didn't notice any
Miss Roberts you mentioned that Gregory
a photographer came to the island during
that time
um how often did You observe Gregory on
the island
um I interacted every day because meals
went down and and and and changing the
sheets and cleaning the room
um so I I see everybody every day
um
there
and when you saw him what was he doing
um
they were doing a there was a shoot on
the
Amber was wearing Alice's clothes and
they were doing a photo shoot on the
beach
um and Greg was taking the pictures
what if anything do you remember about
that particular time that Mr Depp and
Miss heard came down to the island
um we had a there was a
incident between Johnny and Amber here
during that trip
okay can you please describe that
incident
um I
on the evening we kind of called it a
night dinner was finished uh we wrapped
everything up down here at the staff
area in the kitchen
um myself and CJ came to the office uh
uh later on that evening and Johnny was
um
in the office up here
um and he was agitated kind of walking
back and forth I'd asked him if he
needed anything because I figured I
wasn't sure why if he was up here to get
something or was looking for something
which wouldn't be unusual for people to
come up here
um so he was here we talked for a couple
minutes the three of us and a couple
minutes later Amber
um came into the into the office with um
into the office and we were the three of
us were in the office and Amber came in
and she was asking him to
to tell him to come back to the house
um please come back I'm sorry come back
um and uh he
stood
stood here reluctant to go um didn't
want to go and
um a little exchange back and forth he
left the office and got into his vehicle
and started it up and Amber went outside
and stood in front of the vehicle so
that
didn't drive away she was standing in
Amber was standing in front of it and
um again it was she was asking him to
don't leave I'm sorry come back to the
house after a couple minutes she got in
the vehicle and they left to go up back
to their house
what happened after they went back up to
the house
um CJ and I were still in the office and
um weren't really sure
decided that maybe it would be best if
we just drove up there just to make sure
that
um everything was okay and um so we got
in the golf cart and we drove up to
their house
um gone to the parking lot and his
vehicle was in the parking lot and
um
you could hear them you could hear them
inside the house you could hear inside
the house
yelling
um her Amber yelling and Johnny
answering back and you could really hear
what was being said
um we stood there for a couple minutes
uh CJ myself and then
um then you started to hear
um it became Audible
Amber was telling him that he was a
washed up actor he was going to die
alone a fat lonely old man then you
heard uh you hit me with a can you heard
Johnny say you hit me with a can and
then he came down the steps and Amber
was behind him and she had a bottle in
her hand it was removed and there was a
brief pause at the moment I think of
initial shock or
uncertainty of why you know that we were
there they need neither Johnny nor Amber
knew that we were there
um he proceeded to
walk back to the John Deere and
um she again walked he was a city in the
seat each Amber came up to him and was
asking him to come back in the house
that she was sorry please come back in
the house
um and
he didn't come out of the seat and she
was hugging and kissing him and I love
you I love you she was telling him I
loved you he didn't react Joni sat there
eventually uh got out of the John Deere
um and proceeded to start to walk away
at that time Amber started to grab at
him and his shirt and and trying to pull
him back to the house
just basically viciously trying to pull
him back and get him back to the house
and and and yelling at him and at that
point I I was between them and uh felt
it was best and I was getting worried
about what was going to happen and it
was best that um
I remove him from the situation and so
um CJ took Amber back to the house and I
walked Johnny over to the cafe which was
basically 30 seconds away from from the
house because it was the only place I
could take him to at the time
and you mentioned that Miss heard was
viciously trying to pull Mr Depp back
can you explain what you mean by that
um it was like clawing grabbing in his
clothes grabbing his hair trying to like
pull him back like an angry like he was
leaving and come back he couldn't leave
in the vehicle because the keys had been
taken out so there was there was no way
for Johnny to drive away the only way
was for him to to what for him to walk
away and
um it wasn't
um a pleasant situation of of wanting
him to
to not leave and um angry and yell and
and just yelling you know come back come
back don't leave
um and things like that
at any point did Mr Depp um hit or
touched miss her objection leading all
right let's see an objection
Ms Roberts
um how did Mr Depp react to misheard
viciously grabbing him
he he didn't uh he stood there with his
arms by his side and um he he didn't do
anything
Miss Roberts when you were back in the
cafe with Mr death what happened next
um I was concerned because
he I had heard him objection to her
being concerned the responses to
concerned all right okay Ms Roberts
without testifying as how you felt um
what did You observe when you went back
to the cafe with Mr debt
I when we went back to the cafe he had a
mark across the bridge of his nose
um I got a bag of ice to put on his on
it so that it wouldn't swell
um just to make sure that it wasn't
bleeding and I he walked over to the
love seat at the cafe and he laid down
and went to sleep and CJ came back over
and
um I asked CJ to stay there for the
remainder of the evening for the
remainder of the morning
um and I left CJ inside the cafe and I
left Johnny on the camera
when did you next see Miss heard
that that morning I saw I saw her that
morning
how close were you to miss heard when
you interacted with her the next morning
uh conversation
um in
a feet away
when you saw her how did she appear
um
they had guests leaving and
[Music]
kind of a normal morning
um
going down to the beach to to see the
guests leave
what if any makeup was misheard wearing
again I'm not sure she if she wore
makeup on the island if it was it was
very natural looking
what if any injuries Did You observe on
misheard
I didn't observe any
what if any injuries Did You observe on
Mr dapp
the the marking across the bridge of his
nose
after and um when did Miss heard and Mr
dot leave the island
I believe they left that afternoon the
guests left in the morning and I believe
they left that afternoon
after misheard and Mr Depp left the
island what did you do next
um our usual we go into the buildings
and uh
we break them down we empty out the
refrigerators garbage take all the
perishables out of the house
um straighten the place up take the
Linens away
um things like that
what did You observe when you went
through that process
um the island was the island was as it
was when they they arrived the only
thing that was different was the there
was the liquid on the on the deck with a
can I believe of mineral spirits or
something there next to it which had
leaked out onto the deck and then in the
um over the railing were paint brushes
and art supplies paint brushes
um paint tubes big jars of the paints
are in and those were all scattered in
the bush
Miss Roberts when is the first time you
provided testimony about this incident
in December 2015
I believe it was for another case in May
2020.
Ms Roberts how often have you seen Mr
Depp drink alcohol on the island
um he goes through periods of time where
he's been here and he doesn't drink and
it's non-alcoholic facts or something
like that
um it it varies
um sometimes he drinks when he's here
sometimes he doesn't
how often have you seen Miss heard drink
alcohol on the island
um she she drank wine she drank wine
with uh her her drink was wine with
dinner
um maybe in the afternoon but I know
definitely with dinner
Did You observe Miss heard drinking
alcohol when Mr Depp was not drinking
alcohol objection bleeding no sustained
misleading okay
um
how often have you seen Mr Depp drunk
um
I wouldn't know he's a huge tolerance
for alcohol I haven't seen him passed
out drunk
um or anything like that so I uh
he drinks
but I haven't seen him passed out drunk
thank you Miss Roberts nothing further
all right cross-examination thank you
Ms Roberts the salary you receive for
managing the Bahama Island is
approximately ten thousand dollars a
month correct
correct okay and so that comes out to a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year
correct okay and you've been and you've
been receiving that salary for many
years correct
correct right in fact I think you gotta
raise to ten thousand ten dollars in
2018.
do you remember that
no I I don't know the exact number but I
know I get that that a month okay and
that's and that's in addition to all of
the expenses correct
for running the items the expenses of
running the island
I get a salary every month
I'm not sure what you're asking me so
the the other people that are on the
island to the extent they work they get
a different salary right
yes okay and all of the expenses you
have you talked about what you have to
do to provision the island and
everything else and run it all of those
expenses are paid separately correct
correct okay
um and you said you've been managing
this island for 15 years for Mr Depp is
that correct
approximately yes all right now let's
talk for a moment about those two videos
that you you testified to were part of
the house the first video was missing
both the closet and the bathroom correct
I I
I don't remember I'd have to look at it
again all right and the second uh
sorry go ahead
go ahead I'm sorry you didn't come
through go ahead
I'm sorry I think
the video the beads were the closet and
then there was the bathroom next to the
closet okay that was the
second video
do you know who sorry do you know who
took those videos
oh I did okay when did you take those
videos
oh it would have to be uh I'm not sure a
couple years ago maybe longer
I'm not sure okay did you take those
videos for the UK trial
if it was for that right is there a
reason that the closet and the bathroom
were left out of the first video
no I no I stood in the house and did a
circle around of the house
to you to make that video
I'm not sure I'm not sure was it Mr
Waldman
Adam Waldman
I I don't I'm not sure I don't know
can't recall I can't remember who asked
me no I can't okay now the second video
that shows the closet and then there's a
door there would you agree that door
opens up into a bathroom
next to the closet yes okay
and we don't have a video of the the
bathroom correct
to make a video of the bathroom correct
objection relevance
okay
correct
oh sorry
um I'm not sure if anybody asked me to I
don't believe I videotaped the bathroom
and my question was and no one asked you
to videotape the bathroom correct
correct okay now let's talk for a moment
about the logistics of the island so Mr
Depp's house we've seen the inside of
and you said that the cafe was a
30-second walk I think you said how many
yards
and uh walkway to the cafe okay
okay and the cafe is where Mr Depp would
regularly have his meals correct
correct all the guests would have their
meals there okay including Mr Depp and
misheard if she was there and their
children
correct correct okay and then yeah and
then you were located on the other side
of the island correct that's where you
stay
or I stay in in the middle of the island
yes okay how far away is that from the
cafe in the house
objection compounds
sustain the objections how far how far
away is it from the house
where I I stay yes
um probably a three-minute golf cart
ride okay five minute walk okay uh and
then when other guests come I think you
were talking about tents do they stay
intense
the tents were
um
the tents were erected for the the
wedding and then they were dismantled
and sometimes we would erect them if we
were asked to just in case somebody
wanted to stay there but people didn't
stay in the tents they stayed in the
buildings here okay so how how much
accommodation can you handle in the
buildings for other guests I'm not
talking about the house Mr Debb's house
we've seen that
um but how many people can can actually
be accommodated uh in the buildings
um we have a
two-bedroom
uh yurt on Brando Beach we have a
um
a beach house which has a bed in it and
then we have uh
what we call a roundhouse which has a
bed in it as well okay now when Mr Depp
and Ms heard were visiting whether they
had the children there or not
um typically would you bring the meals
to the cafe for each of the meals
you know sometimes I would take them to
the house it depended on where they
wanted to eat
all right and then typically would you
join them for the meal or would you
leave the meal and then come back and
clean up afterwards objection compound
all right
I'll sustain the objection all right
we'll take that one at a time typically
would you bring the meals
to them
myself or myself or one of the the
workers here would take the meals okay
how often was it you that would take
them
um
how often maybe every other day every
day it depended on on how if people were
eating in their buildings or eating
together all right and would you stay
and eat the meal with them or would you
leave
if we were invited for dinner we would
all eat together
um usually we would take the food to the
places and leave
and then would you be called to come
pick them up
no no we would sometimes go back in the
evenings
um on our own
um and and clean up and and turn some of
the lights off and sometimes we would do
it in the morning it depended on what
was happening okay so other than
bringing the meals and it could be you
or somebody else uh how often did you
interact with Mr Depp and Ms heard
during the days
when they were on the island
on average every day
in what context other than delivering
the meals and picking them up
what would you see if anything was
needed if everything was all right
um things like that generally passing
them if they were walking or in the
office or or on the beach
okay
now would it be fair to say that you
weren't spending 24 7 with them
no I didn't live with them no okay and
would it be fair to say that you don't
know what they were doing during the
times that you weren't passing them by
or bringing meals
yes unless they were on the beach okay
then I would know but so you wouldn't
know what happened what would be taking
place within the house for example when
you weren't there
correct correct and you wouldn't know
whether Mr Depp was taking drugs correct
correct and you wouldn't know whether Mr
Depp was drinking correct
I would only know by cleaning up and you
wouldn't know well you wouldn't know
from cleaning up necessarily whether it
was Mr dab misheard or somebody else
would you
objection compound
out loud go ahead
please continue
unless
um I would know what it was by what was
in the garbage or left out of who
consumed or what was consumed I would I
would be able to know
and you wouldn't know what arguments if
there were any were taking place in that
house behind closed doors right
correct and you wouldn't know whether
there was any kind of physical abuse
that was taking place behind those
closed doors correct
I wouldn't know correct okay
now let me just take you for a moment to
the December 2015 time frame
how how much advanced notice are you
typically given for when they are when
Mr Depp and his Entourage are going to
arrive and for how long they're going to
stay objection compound
all right I'll
I'll Stand objection all right let's
break it down how much notice are you
given when Mr Depp and his Entourage are
coming
it varies uh sometimes it's a couple
days sometimes it's a couple weeks so
how much notice were you given in
December of 2015 to who would be coming
for Christmas on the Bahama Island
I believe
um sometime in November okay and that
trip
all right and in November how many
people were you told were coming for
Christmas on the island
I don't recall how many I don't
remember many people it was a lot more
than Amber Johnny Lilly Rose Jack and
Lily Rose's boyfriend wasn't it
yes it was in fact it was Amber's
parents correct
I believe so and it was Rocky Pennington
and Josh Drew correct
I believe they were on the list and
Rocky Pennington's parents
yes I believe they were on the list do
you recall them canceling
objection here saying I recall
how is that here all over with the
objection go ahead
I recall there was a change
um to the the guests
when did you learn of that
I don't recall maybe a couple weeks
after maybe the beginning of December
maybe middle of December do you sure do
you recall if it was after December 15
I don't recall did you think that was a
little strange to hear these people were
going to be objections on the island and
suddenly they cancel objection relevance
I'll sustain the objection
why
why objection hearsay
party opponent admission okay
who told you that Amber's parents her
best friend and fiance and her best
friends parents were suddenly canceling
coming for Christmas on the island
objection compound
I allow that good
I
I did receive information that
um they weren't coming and there were
other somebody else was coming instead
and who was that somebody else coming
instead
and they were coming later right
they would be joining that I think was
the words okay
so
on the December 5th on the December trip
you testified about a few arguments
between Amber and Johnny right do you
recall that testimony
yes I do okay you weren't present when
Johnny sustained the gash on his nose
correct
I wasn't there no okay and you weren't
present when the mess was made through
the paints that you've described correct
no and so you don't know whether there
had been a physical altercation and uh
that led to throwing a paint can to try
to slow down Johnny right
no I just heard yelling in the house
okay but that that yelling in the house
wasn't necessarily the same time was it
you don't know do you no it was on the
same
no
okay
now let's talk about
the summer of
2013.
are you aware that Paul Bettany claims
he's never met Amber
objection relevance
and calls for here saying she testified
that he was there on the island and
calls for hearsay
I can ask the question and see if she
says all right I'll have the question go
ahead
can you repeat it are you aware that
Paul Bettany has said that he never met
Amber Heard
okay I don't know that well let's stay
on the summer of 2013 if we can do you
have a recollection of Amber and Johnny
Lily Rose and Jack taking one final trip
on the yacht that Johnny was going to be
selling to JK Rowling
I don't know what year that was I don't
know what year that was but I do
remember the yacht being sold if I if I
tell you it was July of 2013 does that
help refresh your recollection
July 9.
all right now
it doesn't I just know the yacht was
sold okay and you made arrangements did
you not for a captain to to Captain the
yacht and for them to go out on the
yacht
no I didn't have any responsibility for
the yacht and the crew on the yacht okay
do you have a recollection of being
called
because Lily Rose and Jack were upset
and they wanted to leave the yacht and
have a helicopter take them away
objection hearsay and compound I'm
asking whether she has a recollection of
this oh allow the question
ask me it again do you have a
recollection of Lily Rose and Jack being
upset on the yacht and wanting to leave
it immediately at least so you arranged
for a helicopter to come in to fly them
away with Amber objection compound
allow it okay let's just hear
I I don't know if Lily Rose and Jack
were upset
um I do know that
um I did arrange for transportation off
the island
um at the time
and and and in fact Amber went with Lily
Rose correct
it was Amber and her friend in Lily Rose
okay and Jack decided at the last minute
to stay back correct
I don't know if he decided last minute
he stayed okay do you recall Lily Rose
telling you that she was upset because
her father was drinking and trying to
hide it from him objection hearsay all
right I'm asking whether she has to
sustained the objection okay
um then I'll ask the next one do you
recall Mr Depp passing out in the sand
face first
I recall that he was passed out on the
beach he was he was that yeah he was out
on the beach yes okay and and do you
recall Jack calling you because he was
concerned
objection here saying that's just asking
if he called I haven't asked what he
said yeah you did I'll sustain the
objection okay
do you have a recollection of Jack being
present
when Mr Depp was passed out face first
in the sand
and do you have a recollection of Jack
being upset
I I don't have a relection of him being
upset
do you have a recollection of him being
happy about it
I I no I I didn't speak with with Jack
um about it okay
but you recall that Mr Depp was passed
out face first in the sand correct
objection asked an answer I'll sustain
the objection next question all right
thank you
let's talk about makeup for a moment
so
you don't know what type of makeup
regimen Amber uses every day correct
correct okay and in fact you don't know
you said at one point you're not sure
but it's a natural look do you recall
that
yes I do okay and would you agree that
there are a number of different types of
makeup you can use that would still give
you a natural look
objection calls for speculation oh I'll
allow it
okay okay and
son in the Bahamas right
most of the time do you know what amber
wears uh for sunscreen
um I think it was
um at one point I had a brand shishito
or something like that that was on the
island
that we provided
and do you know whether Amber brought
her own as well
you know whether Amber had a skin
condition
I wasn't told okay
but you I take it you didn't ask
no I wouldn't have asked if somebody has
skin condition okay
um
the wedding
the wedding was planned at Sunset
correct
correct and in fact it went forward at
Sunset correct
I went earlier the it was it was earlier
than in than Sunset so your recollection
is that there's no sunset pictures at
the wedding
okay there was there was there was
sunset pictures
okay
so last couple questions the the makeup
or not makeup you were asked whether you
observed any injuries on Amber in the
December 2015 time frame
do you believe Amber would cover up
bruises to hide them from the kids
objection calls for circulation
do you have any understanding based on
your knowledge of Amber whether she
would try to cover up any bruises or
Cuts same objection them from the kids
I'll sustain the objection
I you said that you didn't believe that
that Amber was wearing much makeup but
you said she participated in a photo
shoot in December 2015 do you recall
that
yes I do do you know whether Amber was
wearing any makeup for a photo shoot
I'm not sure the the part that I saw she
was in and out of the water
do you do you know whether Amber would
want to show bruises or Cuts in a photo
shoot objection calls for speculation no
sustain the objection I have no further
questions thank you all right redirect
we do
Miss Roberts how many times have you
seen Mr Depp consume drugs objection
leading all right sustained
um
Miss brotherhof asked you about Mr Depp
passed out on the beach how would you
describe Mr Depp when you saw him on the
beach
um he was he was passed out I picked him
up and brushed him off and and he said I
left him underneath the I believe he was
in a hammock and I I believe he'd fallen
asleep or he was asleep and the hammock
had overturned
um and I picked him up and
um brushed him off and
left him um on underneath the Lanai with
Jack
okay no further questions thank you Miss
Roberts subject to recall Mr Roberts
since you're subject to recall did not
discuss your testimony with anybody and
just not watch anything about this case
okay ma'am
okay thank you very much all right thank
you
all right your next Witness
Dr Shannon Curry she'll come right now
Doctor Who Shannon Curry can you is it
c-u-r-r-y c-u-r-r-y okay thank you
everybody
[Music]
foreign
um
but this would be with us moment there
in this case in a penalty of law I do
good morning Dr curry good morning
I'm Wayne Dennison
could you state your State your full
name for the record
Shannon Curry
what do you do for a living
I am a clinical and forensic
psychologist
what's your educational background
I received well I started college at
Georgetown University I then transferred
to the University of California Irvine
where I received my bachelor's degree in
psychology and social behavior
I completed my Master's Degree in
Psychology at the at Pepperdine
University I went on to complete my
doctoral degree in Clinical Psychology
at Pepperdine University which included
several training rotations at different
practicum sites those are essentially
clinical rotations we do to learn
various types of psychology you learn
how to do psychological assessment
counseling Etc and you do that in a
variety of different settings
and then I completed a year-long
doctoral internship at an American
Psychological Association accredited
doctoral internship you do this year
before you get your degree and that was
at tripler Army Medical Center it's
traditionally a military internship they
did admit to civilians I was lucky
enough to be one of them I then
completed two years of postdoctoral
training at Hawaii State Hospital a
locked forensic psychology facility and
that's where you essentially have
individuals with severe mental illness
who have committed crimes
have you done any additional coursework
or educational work I have so uh after I
completed my doctorate and my
postdoctoral training I obtained a it's
called a postdoctoral master of science
degree and clinical psychopharmacology
uh that is uh for partial fulfillment of
prescription privileges meaning that
it's part of what we need to be able to
prescribe medications as a psychologist
because psychologists don't
traditionally prescribe and we can do
that with certain military jurisdictions
in other states
I also obtained Advanced Training in the
gottman method of couples therapy
I completed all three levels of training
and then I'm also a gottman educator for
several workshops involving helping
parents learn how to prepare to bring
their baby home and helping couples
without serious problems improve their
relationships what's the gottman method
the gottman method is a highly
research-based method of couples therapy
it's very struck captured so different
than what many people expect when they
think about couples therapy I always
tell my clients I don't want them to
come in just tell each other all their
problems and then have an awkward silent
drive home in this therapy they come in
they complete a really structured
assessment in the beginning so they
complete a bunch of questions it gives
me a ton of information about their
relationship before we even get started
and really identify as the areas we're
going to Target with structured
interventions during each session I
think of it almost like a class
okay
um
did you get in the course of your
education any specialized training any
what specialized training
I did so uh
my internship specifically was dedicated
to
essentially working with post-traumatic
stress disorder traumatic stress a lot
of my training has been with
psychological assessment and testing and
then my training during practicum and
then in my postdoctoral work was
dedicated to working with trauma
populations and also conducting forensic
psychological assessments often times
forensic psychological assessments
actually refers to doing testing and an
interview and a couple other things four
purposes related to law so it's the
application of psychology to the courts
to to legal issues and sometimes that
also involves doing assessments for the
military to determine whether somebody
has sustained a mental disability after
combat
um you indicated that you did some work
at tripler what's tripler and what's the
work you did
tripler Army Medical Center is a
hospital and
in Hawaii if anybody's ever gotten to
have a vacation in Hawaii it said giant
Pink building there and um it's one of
the top training sites for military
psychologists I was very very lucky to
be able to train there they have
wonderful funding and a lot of new
research going on particularly for PTSD
but really for all areas of mental
health while I was there I did rotations
in Family Psychology so doing family
therapy I worked with children but I
also did a neuropsychology rotation
learning really the ins and outs of
advanced psychological assessment
identifying not just mental issues
mental sort of Mental Illness but also
traumatic brain injuries after trauma
and doing those PTSD evaluations and
then also working with service members
who were struggling with a whole host of
issues military stressors normal life
stressors and then also those who
sustained tremendous trauma from combat
still continue to work with the military
I do actually our practice I
my practice is very focused on military
service members veterans and their
families
um
what work have you done in Prior
litigation matters
well uh
most of my litigation if we're talking
about civil work that is mostly been
reports so this is my first time
testifying in a civil matter uh the
majority of my forensic work has been in
criminal law or providing psychological
assessments and then I produce uh really
methodical report which is typically
reviewed by a judge and a determination
is made or usually there's a settlement
uh beforehand
um
do you work uh in connection with with
any particular courts I do so I I'm
actually not sure if I'm on the list
anymore in Honolulu but
um I am a certified forensic evaluator
for the state of Hawaii which means that
um I have been appointed by the court to
conduct evaluations for matters that are
presented uh and then I'm also on the
list of forensic evaluators in several
courts in Southern California and then
I'm also I'm contracted by the military
the Department of Defense uh now and
again for evaluations of PTSD from
service members okay you mentioned uh
PTSD a couple of times now yes what are
you referring to there
so PTSD is a mental illness
it can develop after a person has been
exposed to a traumatic event and
our diagnostic statistical manual the
DSM is sort of the authoritative Manual
of mental illnesses that we it's
considered our Bible of mental illness
we go there for diagnoses and according
to that there's a specific type of
trauma that a person must experience for
them to be able to qualify for a
diagnosis of PTSD and that's an event
that is life-threatening it can also
involve sexual assault and you can
experience that either directly but you
can also be traumatized if you've seen
it happen to somebody else or if it's
happened unexpectedly or violently to
somebody close to you a family member or
a friend and then there's also a
provision for people who are First
Responders if they're encountering
really traumatic information regularly
that qualifies as a trauma now there are
a number of symptoms that can develop
well sure we'll talk about that okay
um
do you hold any credentials relevant to
the work that you do
well I am a licensed psychologist
um where
in California and Hawaii
okay and any other certifications or
other credentials
not that I can think of off the top of
my head other other than the training
with the gottman method of couples
therapy okay
have you worked with the Hawaii
Department of Courts and Corrections
yes I have in what capacity well I am I
so that I guess would be a credential so
I am a certified forensic evaluator for
the state of Hawaii
in connection with your doctorate was
there a research component
there was so uh would you like me to
tell you about it yes please okay so I
conducted a research study while I was
at Pepperdine completing my doctorate
it's called a dissertation so when
you're obtaining your doctorate you
contribute something to the scientific
field that you're in and typically that
involves doing what we call novel
science so you're doing an experiment
you're finding out new information and
helping the field progress so I did
research in Peru and I was essentially
looking at the effectiveness of a
therapy intervention there for kids who
were growing up in this community called
ayakucho which was exposed to 20 years
of Guerrilla warfare the longest gorilla
war in the history of the world and
there were a lot of issues in that
Community
tremendous trauma and my research was
around finding interventions that were
really effective for that community
where do you work now
I work for the curry psychology group
what does the curry psychology group do
we're a multi-specialty mental health
center so we have neuropsychologists who
do testing for kids we have therapists
individual therapists couples therapists
family therapists we even have a
meditation teacher we basically try to
meet the needs of our community and we
highly specialize in working with
military personnel in their families
who's the curry and Curry psychology
group I I'm Dr Curry
how many people work for you
as of right now I believe it's 13.
how long have you been doing this kind
of work
for about 15 years
how much of your therapy practice
focuses on treating individuals
I would say about half of it as
individuals half as couples
training of students
I do
what's that
so uh we have several unlicensed
professionals at our office and
um they're earning their additional
hours so that they can get licensed so
they're able to see clients and then I
meet with them regularly to supervise
them discuss their cases provide them
with information about different
diagnoses interventions and treatment
methods
how do you get involved in this case
I was contacted by Ms Camille Vasquez
one of the attorneys for Mr debb okay
and
what was the nature of the contact
Miss Vasquez called me and indicated
that she might be interested in having
me meet the legal team so that I could
discuss my expertise and possibly
provide my opinions related to the
matter yeah what were you asked to
provide uh expert opinion on
so initially my role that I understood
at the time was to review the case
materials and provide my opinions
regarding anything that I noticed that
was consistent or even inconsistent with
the psychological science that exists
today on intimate partner violence in Mr
Depp and Ms herd's relationship
but all right you used a phrase there uh
intimate partner violence what are you
talking about so there are a multitude
of different definitions depending on
the source or the state but essentially
intimate partner violence is abuse it
could be physical psychological uh and
it's from one partner to another in an
intimate relationship
um
did your role in this case evolve over
time
yes uh it shifted so I was retained uh
in at the end of January 2021 and then
uh had just barely begun to review the
documents the case was postponed and
then in October 2021
um I was asked by Council to provide a
psychological evaluation of misheard
did uh were you ever asked to do a
psychological psychological evaluation
of Mr dapp no
okay
what types of documents did you consider
in this analysis
so I reviewed uh quite a few documents
as part of my evaluation that included
all of the case documents Ms heard's
medical records by Dr Kipper her prior
mental health treatment records I
believe I reviewed records from Dr Amy
Banks Dr Bonnie Jacobs Dr Cohen Connell
Cohen
um
uh and also a significant portion of my
review involved notes from nurse Aaron
fellati at the time Aaron Borum who
spent a significant time with Ms heard
in her direct company I also reviewed
exhibits quite a few audio recordings a
video recording several video recordings
or possibly photographs I might be
getting them confused
and multiple witness statements
testimony and declarations
do there come a time when you've met
directly with Ms hurt
yes I did so in conducting my evaluation
I met with Miss heard on two separate
dates December 10th and December 17
2021. uh approximately how much time
you've spent with Miss heard
so the evaluation we spent 12 hours
directly with one another however there
were more there were more hours involved
in the evaluation with some breaks so we
spent seven hours together on the first
day December 10th
um not necessarily together because
there was a one hour lunch break and
about a half hour with breaks split up
through the day and then on the 17th we
spent a little more than eight hours in
the evaluation from start to finish with
a one hour break and another half hour
of breaks distributed throughout the day
as there was as a result of the work
that you performed did you form any
opinions with respect to Ms heard I did
what were those opinions
I uh the results of misheard's
evaluation supported two diagnoses
borderline personality disorder and
histrionic personality disorder
what is a diagnosis
a diagnosis is a way that we essentially
that psychologists psychiatrists anybody
in the mental health field thinks about
a disorder it helps us to communicate a
set of symptoms that a person is
experiencing and along with that set of
symptoms it it tells other professionals
a lot about how those symptoms might
have developed how that person might
behave perceive the world it also drives
treatment the real purpose is to
determine what sort of interventions
will be most effective for the person
yeah
um
previously you made reference to uh I
think you called it the DSM-5 what's
that
so the DSM-5 that stands for the
diagnostic statistical manual uh version
five and uh that contains every
diagnosis we use in mental health and uh
we it's
it's the authoritative Manual of mental
diagnoses
is performing diagnoses something you
typically do in your line of work yes
um
so your reference to personality
disorders
what's a personality disorder
to understand a personality disorder I
think it can be helpful first to kind of
Define personality
so personality something we take for
granted but these are the traits the
characteristics the way we think we feel
and we act that make us who we are and
these traits are pretty stable over time
and across situations we might uh you
know be sure to mind our p's and q's
when we're meeting somebody new but
overall if somebody were to describe us
or if we were to describe ourselves we
have a pretty good sense of who we are
sometimes an easy way to think of it is
imagining how you might describe a
brother or sister or a child if you have
children their personalities are pretty
clear to you a personality disorder
is some sort of dysfunction in those
enduring traits so as opposed to other
types of mental illness when you think
about something like depression that's
episodic it comes and it goes and when
it's treated with medication it can
pretty much be completely mitigated or
minimized in a person's life and their
personality is still there separate from
the depression when we have a
personality disorder they're going to be
disturbances in several different areas
that are visible in almost all different
facets of their life
is there a manner in which uh
personality disorders are commonly
diagnosed
so they can be diagnosed in a treating
environment treating psychologists or a
therapist or a psychiatrist simply does
a diagnostic interview which involves
assessing multiple areas of a person's
history back down through child I'm
going to stop you for a second what's a
treating environment
sometimes I'll slip into these words I
apologize so a treating environment in
therapy if somebody is going in for
treatment
um the psycho the mental health provider
will ask them questions to find out what
sort of symptoms they've experienced and
what sort of things have occurred in
their life that might be consistent with
these disorders or rule out these
disorders prove that there's no reason
for these disorders to be considered
they might also pay attention to their
observations of the client over time and
new information the client provides them
the most reliable way however to ever
come about a diagnosis really is through
a Comprehensive Psychological assessment
and I might use the words assessment
examination testing interchangeably they
all mean the same thing it's combining
information from multiple different
sources
one main source is psychological testing
using validated objective measures that
means that they've been tested they've
been shown to be accurate for testing
what you want to test and in the
environment you're testing so they're
measures specific for court environments
where someone might respond differently
you integrate that with the same
interview I was telling you that people
would do for therapy we do that as well
and then in a courtroom setting you're
going to look at all the legal records
all of those documents corroborating
information to sort of check your
hypotheses that may be developing and
also check against the examinee
statements to confirm whether you have
enough evidence of a certain diagnosis
so what's a clinical interview
a clinical interview is a very
comprehensive interview it includes a
person's entire life history
as well as very specifically looks at
any symptoms they might have this can
start as far back as birth you might
find out if there were any issues with
their delivery any genetic issues any
intellectual issues how did they do what
was their home life like how is
discipline handled what's their
relationship with their primary
caregivers were they right raised by an
aunt an uncle their parents how many
siblings do they have how do they get
along with their siblings how many times
did they have to move or was there any
abuse did they have any really
significant life experiences that come
to mind when they think about their
childhood how were they as a student did
they need special services did they get
in trouble at school and you do this you
continue on high school what were their
Hobbies did they play sports how many
friends did they have did they have any
trouble keeping those friendships then
you get into adulthood did they go to
college did they not go to college how
come what sort of jobs have they held
how did those jobs go how did they end
that's always an important question what
sort of romantic relationships have they
been involved in how do they identify
sexually culturally
um let's see what else what sort of
symptoms have they experienced you go
through the entire gamut of some of the
main symptoms you might screen for
depression any disorganized thinking
that means thinking that isn't
necessarily in touch with reality and
any current distress they may be
happening having today
how did you conclude that misheard
suffers from the personality disorders
that you identified
so uh there was information that
supported it from multiple sources
I conducted testing including one of the
main tests that I used she obtained
scores that were consistent with those
diagnoses and then I also
um there was evidence of those diagnoses
in her records and in her self-report
all right Council why don't we just go
ahead and pause for a second while we go
and take our morning recess okay ladies
and gentlemen we'll go ahead and take
our 15-minute morning recess do not
discuss the case and do not do any
outside research okay
Jordan when would you like to reconvene
uh give me a moment sir
and Doctor since you're on the stand now
do not discuss your testimony with
anybody to include the attorneys at this
point okay all right let's go ahead and
we'll come back at 11 45 okay all right
thank you
all right
foreign
ready for the jury okay
foreign
all right you have your seat and your
next question sir
thank you your honor
but Dr Curry before the break uh you
were talking about some of the uh
factors that you considered in
determining uh misheard suffers from
personality disorders and one of them I
think the last one you said before you
left was self-report what do you mean by
that
so uh the self-report would be things
that misheard indicated to me
specifically
um so there were a couple of
characteristics that she noted in
herself report that were consistent with
these personality disorders the first
was actually my own behavioral
observations of her based on her
self-report so one of the Hallmark
characteristics of histrionic borderline
or sorry histrionic personality disorder
is sort of a overly dramatic
presentation we call this
impressionistic speech so it tends to be
very flowery it uses a lot of
descriptive words like magical wonderful
and it can go on for quite some time and
yet it really lacks any substance so at
the end you're left wondering what was
just said or what the answer is to the
actual question so that occurred a
number of times and it also represented
the kind the quick shifts you'll see
between emotions so she would suddenly
be one way and then she would become
very animated or very
sad and when people are displaying these
emotions with this personality disorder
it there's a sense of shallowness to it
people who are observing them will feel
like uh it's almost play acting and they
might not be able to put their finger on
it but part of it is because of the
rapidness with which the person can
switch emotions and also the lack of
substance They Don't Really refer to I
feel this way they might describe
emotions they might describe events but
very rarely and I misheard did not say I
feel vulnerable she never really
indicated a vulnerable feeling of her
own
than the substance of herself report so
when I was asking her information about
her history
we're going to ask more about that later
I was just trying to get a sense of what
a self-report was oh okay
um what psychological tests did you
perform okay so psychological tests I uh
I'll just go in order so first of all I
asked her a couple questions from
something called the mini mental status
exam that's really just a fancy way of
saying that I wanted to make sure that
she was alert and oriented to we call it
person place and time that means she
knew who she was she knew who I was she
knew where we were and she knew the date
that make that way I can ensure that
she's able to participate in the
evaluation and understand what's
happening I then
um administered something called the
Minnesota
multi-phasic personality inventory to
the two means that it's the second
edition and this is something we call an
objective measure so
um it uh asks
567 questions more statements than the
person either agrees or disagrees with
them how much the statement represents
them and this test has been around since
1943 there are more than 10 000 studies
showing that it is appropriate for
determining somebody's personality
traits
it measures all of those things I sort
of mentioned how a person thinks feels
and behaves in multiple different
aspects of their lives it also measures
very accurately any signs of mental
illness or dysfunction and the reason I
also really like this test whenever
you're using a test for an evaluation
that's going to be used in a forensic
setting people have a lot of incentive
to present themselves in a way that's
going to benefit their case and they may
want to look like they're sicker than
they really are they may want to look
much healthier than they really are and
some of those incentives they may not
even realize that they're intending to
do that so it can be conscience
conscious or unco conscious but you
really need to have a test that can
check for that and the mmpi2 has a set
of validity scales we call them these
are scales that measure really the
truthfulness and accuracy with which
person is approaching the test and these
these scales on this particular test
have been so well researched over many
decades that they've become very nuanced
and they can tell us a lot about if
somebody's for instance exaggerating are
they elevating one of the scales that
shows that they're exaggerating on
purpose are they exaggerating in a
manner that's more like a cry for help
are they exaggerating in a manner that's
clever and sophisticated or more obvious
and then the same exact thing goes for
Trying to minimize symptoms we have a
number of scales that can show us all
the different if somebody's trying to
say they're the most wonderful person on
Earth or if they're just trying to deny
problems and if they're doing that again
in a very clever way or more of an
obvious way so that test was my choice
for this case there's one other reason
I'd like to add is that part of my
evaluation was one of the reasons was to
assess whether misheard has
post-traumatic stress disorder which I
told you about earlier
um as a result of the incidents that
she's alleged occurred by Mr Depp and
that's a really tough disorder to find
out if somebody's faking it or not it's
one of the most easily faked disorders
most of us know what it feels like to
feel anxious and a lot of people have
seen war movies and movies that depict
somebody having PTSD in fact some
research has shown that if you give
someone a diagnostic checklist and said
show that you have PTSD they can do it
96 percent of the time just someone on
the street so you really need a test
that's very sensitive to that and the
mmpi2 has been shown in multiple studies
to be excellent at detecting those
attempts okay you keep using mmpi too
that's the abbreviation that you folks
use for the I'm sorry if I hadn't said
that that's the Minnesota multiphasic
personality inventory
uh what other uh psychological testing
did you perform
so I also performed the
clinician-administered PTSD scale Dash 5
and that Dash 5 links it to the
diagnosis for PTSD and our current
diagnostic manual the fifth version
to do that test you first administer
something called the life events
checklist and the life events checklist
both of these tests by the way were
developed by the national Center for
PTSD with the Department of Veterans
Affairs but the life events checklist
lists 16 different very stressful life
events that people can go through that
are often can be associated with
developing PTSD and then it also has a
17th item that you can fill in if you
feel like you've been through something
really difficult that wasn't included
now I like to also add something called
the life events checklist five interview
which digs a little bit deeper into the
person's childhood as well to find out
if they what sort of there's so many
different things that can be difficult
growing up and also it's very important
that you have the person determine which
of the events they've listed let's say
they have a number of different types of
traumas which one do they feel like was
the most traumatic for them which one
still causes them to feel distressed
when they talk about it
and sometimes they can't just identify
one and then that has a that leads to
your next decision so if they have
multiple different similar types of
events like seeing combat then you might
use that as the worst one the multiple
similar so that looks like uh you
describe an anchor we call it to do the
testing and we would maybe describe the
anchor as the worst of my combat
experience okay now somebody had
multiple different traumas from
different times in their life like
childhood abuse and then went to combat
and had some horrible things happen
there you would do the
clinician-administered PTSD scale test
the one that comes after you do one for
the childhood event and a separate one
for the adulthood event
does this clinician administered PTSD
scale have a handy abbreviation it does
we'll call it the Caps vibe that that's
actually what it goes by okay
um
how common is the use of the mppi
mmpi2 in your profession the mmpi2 is
actually the most commonly used
assessment worldwide by mental health
professionals and in forensic settings
for the court why'd you use it I used it
for that purpose and for its excellent
validity in those settings across
genders across ethnicities for different
reasons and when I keep saying validity
by the way what I mean is accuracy or uh
and I'll try to work that in but then
also for detecting the accuracy with
which a person reports PTSD
um is that scaled in some way I'm sorry
what was that does that make use of a
scale in some way
the mmpi too do you mean specifically
for PTSD yes there's actually a
combination of scales you want to look
for you would never make the diagnosis
just based on one scale alone or even on
the tests alone you'd integrate other
data sure
how did you administer the mmpi2 to
misheard
I provided her the test on an iPad she
essentially had her own little desk area
and then an iPad she hit start it
provides her with the instructions and
then the it gives her 567 statements in
order for each one she Taps true or
false
what did you learn about misheard from
the results of the mfpi too
quite a bit I um I wrote up a 25-page
interpretation outline
um
it has numerous numerous scales so one
of the reasons I like this measure so
much is that it can tell you so much
about multiple different traits and
tendencies and mental issues
one of the primary things I learned was
that she had a very
sophisticated way of minimizing any
personal problems
um I also learned that she tends to uh
well there were a number of
characteristics that were consistent
with the eventual diagnoses but
um
some of the primary characteristics and
I'm going to try to condense 25 Pages
here were essentially
externalization of blame
tending to have a lot of inner hostility
that is attempted to be controlled
a tendency to be very self-righteous but
to also deny that self-righteousness and
to judge others critically against these
sort of high standards for moral value
but also to deny doing that essentially
to to claim that one is uh
very non-judgmental and accepting and
yet very full of Rage really and um and
these aren't facts but her score is
essentially correlated so they were
consistent with other people who obtain
these scores who have been shown through
many many many studies do have these
very specific traits so externalization
of blame a lot of inner anger and
hostility sometimes that anger among
these groups with similar scores these
people might have that anger kind of
explode out at times they tend to be
very passive aggressive
they may be self-indulgent very
self-centered
um they uh could use manipulation
tactics to try to get their needs met
very needy of attention acceptance
approval
um
they tend to distance people who are
close to them initially they may seem
very Charming they're very socially
sophisticated actually that was a major
component on there
they have a capacity to kind of offer
some of their faults but in a way but
only the ones that people think of
lightly and can all relate to and so
they can present as very fair imbalanced
but in actuality they really might uh
uh be very judgmental of others and
unaware of problems in their behavior
and their thinking so after you provide
the the examination by by the iPad what
do you do
so once they've completed the test
you can have it scored by the computer
immediately
it's a very very complex test to
interpret but right away you get a list
of what's called critical items and
these are just some uh a couple of the
items the statements that are presented
that are more clearly symptom-based and
I always follow up with the examinee
some of these might have to do with
suicide some of them might have to do
with other symptoms that you'd just like
to get a little bit more information on
because sometimes an examinee might tell
you they're completely fine when you're
doing your interview with them and that
they have no symptoms and then when they
take the test it says that they're
having trouble sleeping or they struggle
with nausea all the time or they feel
very anxious and so you want to follow
up on that
okay what's a code Type
a code Type
let me think of how to explain this very
very simply so
the main scales and I keep referring to
scales these are just uh
the main scores that come up on this
test we can refer to them as codes
and when I was saying that Ms heard's
scores could be compared to certain
groups of people that had been
researched before to obtain similar
scores
the research has shown that certain
people will have certain scores that
kind of Spike on this okay and so all of
those traits that I were described was
describing those are traits that are
found in these code types so it means
that number two score number two was
high and score number six was high and
so if we have those two scores we're
both High then that's a 2 6 code type
and these code types what code Type was
misheard misheard had the clearest code
Type was three six but then she also had
some other code types that were less
significant what characteristics are
associated with a three six code Type
so a three six code Type
a lot of that anger is expressed in this
code Type um there can be actually a lot
of Cruelty uh usually with people who
are less powerful uh
actually when you see this code Type you
want to if you can to follow up with
subordinates co-workers people who may
have observed their behavior more
closely
the three six code type is very
concerned with their image very
attention seeking
uh
very prone to externalizing blame to a
point where uh it's unclear whether they
can even admit to themselves
that they do have responsibility in
certain areas a lot of suppressed and
denied anger but the anger is very
present will explode out and a lot of
issues in their close relationships
how does MS hurt's code Type fit in with
your overall opinion as to personality
disorders well
um
this might be an appropriate time to
describe a little bit about these
personality disorders because I think
what you'll hear is that there's a lot
of consistency there so borderline
personality disorder is a disorder of
stability it's instability and it's
instability and personal relationships
it's instability in their emotions it's
instability in their behavior
and it's instability in their sense of
self and their identity
and that instability is really driven by
this underlying
Terror of abandonment
so one of the key features also this
disorder and all of it is like Pistons
of an engine kind of firing off and
igniting one another
but when somebody is afraid of being
abandoned by their partner or by anybody
else in their environment and they have
this disorder they'll make desperate
attempts to prevent that from happening
and those desperate attempts could be
physical aggression it could be
threatening it could be harming
themselves but these are behaviors that
are usually very extreme and very
concerning to the people around them
um
uh the anger is typically what
sadly it's counteractive right so the
thing these people fear most is being
abandoned but over time the anger that
explosive anger that they show when
somebody is uh needing space or when
somebody's really not doing anything
wrong because a lot of times they read
into things that they perceive as being
a slight to them or being somebody
intending to harm them that actually
isn't happening they'll exaggerate it
and they'll explode they'll react in
this heightened manner that is just
exhausting for their Partners oftentimes
their Partners will
uh try to make them happy at first and
really allow themselves to be a punching
bag thinking that they can somehow solve
this problem that somehow they can make
this better and eventually it just
overwhelms them histrionic personality
disorders very before we move on okay
um
are you familiar with the term emotional
reactivity I am what is that
so emotional reactivity is very common
in the diagnosis
so essentially uh like I said there's
instability and emotions people with
borderline personality disorder are
often misdiagnosed as having bipolar
disorder because they can be up and down
they can look very depressed then they
can look very elated but these changes
are happening within a matter of hours
somebody with bipolar disorder these are
this is a clinical depression lasting
days weeks a clinical Mania where
sometimes they even need to be
hospitalized because they're so
grandiose they clear out their bank
account and go to Vegas and spend it all
they're acting in some very bizarre ways
with uh borderline personality disorder
you're having these fluctuating moods
constantly and again this
hypersensitivity to being slighted or
feeling offended really driven by the
fear that if you're offended or slighted
if the therapist comes in two minutes
late or if somebody shows up to dinner
two minutes late that they might be
abandoning you and it's not as if the
borderline is considering themselves
abandoned in that moment but they just
know that they have this overwhelming
emotion and there are no attempts to
control that emotion there's no there
are no attempts to regulate it so if
they're in the middle of the restaurant
and they feel offended they're going to
start the fight people are going to see
it or they might just start crying or
break down but they'll make a lot of
accusations and that reactivity is when
you're gonna just you're gonna see a lot
of this escalation of the bizarre
behavior they can react violently they
can react aggressively they will often
physically prevent their partner from
trying to leave if their partner wants
to get space from all of this intense
emotion and oftentimes they will be
abusive to their Partners in these
situations sometimes they'll physically
restrain them from leaving and become
injured that way but also people with
borderline personality disorder it seems
to be a predictive factor for women who
Implement violence against their partner
and one of the most common tactics that
they'll use is actually physically
assaulting and then getting harmed
themselves
but mostly we call this administrative
violence the essentially this is saying
that they'll make threats using the
legal system so
they might say that they are going to
file a restraining order or claim abuse
or they might do these things to
essentially try to keep their partner
from leaving in the moment again they're
not consciously thinking I'm going to
keep my partner from leaving right now
they're just thinking I can't stand this
I hate my partner they went from
idealizing to suddenly devaluing because
it's a hurt and they'll do anything to
express that big emotion of anger
your honor may we approach all right yes
sir
foreign
you indicated uh
you were talking about emotional
reactivity
uh
what if any emotional reactivity did you
uh observe in your review and let's do
this one at a time okay
so there were a couple indications to me
uh
first I I can sort of think about it
with the treatment record so
particularly uh Dr
um
Cohen Connells am I getting the name
right I feel like for some reason in my
mind I might have just reversed it
but Dr Cohen's records I did reverse it
uh he actually refers to this reactivity
quite a bit and to Ms herd's temper and
that that temper it's often branded or
being hot-headed is really
characteristic of borderline personality
disorder
um
as is they're very Charming personable
nature it's it's this is a disorder of
contradictions
uh in nurse filotti's notes
um she had I thought there was something
interesting she references a night when
they're out to dinner I believe in
London and she provided positive
reinforcement to Ms heard because Miss
hurt had been uh disappointed by a
mistake made by the server and it sort
of references how previously she might
have criticized the server and become
upset by that and that she didn't this
time and so that that had been some sort
of a step forward uh
and there was also an indication
actually in Dr hughes's Dr Hughes is a
forensic psychologist who had been
appointed by Ms heard to conduct as an
evaluation as well in Ms hughes's
interview of Ms heard Ms heard disclosed
that she had cut her arm in the past
which is a typical reactive type thing
somebody with this diagnosis can do it's
one of the symptoms
um and that's sort of all I can think of
top of my mind from the treatment
records moving into some of the
Declarations
or deposition testimony
what struck me was Ms Raquel
Pennington's testimony she's a former
friend of Ms herds and she indicated she
told a story about I suppose they were
shopping for Thanksgiving accoutrement
something to prepare for Thanksgiving
and miss her struck her in the face
sort of out of the blue
um which is I I thought was interesting
because that is one of those
signs of borderline personality disorder
where if if a friend or a loved one
isn't meeting your needs in that moment
borderline people with borderline
personality disorder can be very caring
in their relationships as long as their
needs are being met they feel that their
needs should be met when they want them
met at a specific level and if they're
not then that anger that sense of harm
causes them to react so the Striking
Miss Pennington per Ms Pennington's
report in the Declaration or the
testimony I thought was pretty
consistent
and then uh Miss heard's own self
description okay we're gonna
um I'm gonna ask you a question about
sure you you indicated Miss Pennington
uh was a former friend yes of misheard
is there uh a relationship between
borderline personality disorder and uh
intimate relationships
yes so uh so the instability definitely
translates to their relationships you'll
see relationships start very intensely
people will uh somebody with borderline
personality disorder perceives the
relationship as extremely close this
pattern of idealizing and devaluing is
definitely at play they do this with
their lovers and also with their friends
and so this might be the perfect person
their perfect soulmate friend perfect
soulmate partner and their engagement
and the relationship is very alluring
very Charming to the other person
um and so initially everything seems
great but what occurs is that reality
sets in people are not perfect even when
we have a lot of in common with them
um
whereas most of us can accept somebody
as a whole somebody who has a little bit
of flaws and still think this is my
great friend who always all constantly
running late for dinner
the person with borderline personality
disorder things are in these extremes
this black and white we call it
splitting and so that person goes from
being idealized the perfect person to
dumpster they are totally devalued they
are the worst friend they don't care
anything about me I have better people
around and then there will be a repair
because the person with this disorder
does feel remorseful after they have
these reactions angry tell their friend
off but over time it wears away at these
relationships and so what you'll usually
see is many many transitions in their
friendships over the years people who
have sort of Fallen by the wayside who
were really
very close knit at one time and then but
there's not a lot of consistency in the
long term you'll also see that with
their Intimate Relationships many many
relationships but none that are
particularly long term
how does borderline personality disorder
relate to identity issues
so again that instability also travels
toward identity
when I was describing personality
earlier I was talking a little bit about
those traits we have that help us know
who we are when you have borderline
personality disorder that actually is
not something you understand so people
with this disorder actually take on the
identity of the people they're spending
time with because it's comforting it's
very uncomfortable to not know who you
are some people with this disorder will
describe a feeling of emptiness when
they feel like they've been abandoned
because now they don't know who they are
in the world and so when somebody with
this disorder is going through that
initial enmeshment phase with new people
and they're idealizing them they often
will take on the identities of those
people so they may mimic them in a lot
of ways they might mimic the way they
dress their interests the way they talk
and for this reason the people around
somebody with this disorder kind of from
the outside may feel like wait I thought
you were this way and now you're
advocating for this and this is your new
main interest in Life or the thing
you're throwing yourself into all
completely music tastes might change
Hobbies will change the way they dress
okay
in addition to
borderline personality disorder I
understand that you
diagnosed another personality disorder
what's that so histrionic personality
disorder and these are really two sides
of the same coin they belong to the same
cluster we call these clusters it's a
way to organize personality disorders in
that DSM and this cluster is described
as the personality disorders that are
dramatic erratic and emotional okay so
unpredictable but really having to do
with emotions and relationships
they're very similar whereas I was
saying that borderline personality
disorder a lot of the key features that
you're going to notice are instability
when it comes to histrionic a lot of the
key features are going to be drama and
shallowness
similarly with borderline personality
disorder there's this under this
underlying Drive of avoiding abandonment
with histrionic personality disorder
that underlying Drive is to always be
the center of attention because if you
don't have that attention on you it
feels similarly to borderline
personality disorder you feel pretty
empty like you don't have that sense of
being or of value okay so whereas
borderline personality disorder might
have more of the visible reactivity if
somebody seems to be leaving with
histrionic personality disorder what
you're going to see is Extreme
discomfort with not being the center of
attention extreme efforts to be the
center of attention and when they feel
that they're not the center of attention
you will see some strange things making
up stories to try to get attention often
taking on a victim or princess role
those two role holes in particular are
pretty consistent seeking caretaking
borderline personality disorder is
similar because with borderline
personality disorder these shifts of
identity and the splitting you might see
somebody go from being in the DSM it
describes it as a needy supplicant of
help seeking the perfect caretaker to
suddenly being the Avenger against
Injustice or thinking that their partner
is a terrible person with histrionic
what you'll see is somebody who
um it wants to be the center of
attention has sort of that
impressionistic speech very flowerly
uh very enthusiastic but nothing's
really being said
the moment your attention wears away
because they're so demanding for
attention that's when they might take
the victim role or the princess role and
even make up stories sometimes those
stories are to bolster the victim role
sometimes those stories are just to make
them look more interesting or
accomplished in their mind so that they
can get respect and attention that way
is there a relation between histrionic
personality disorder and attractiveness
attractiveness there is strangely and
this is always one of the trickiest
things to talk about because how do you
I mean how is that a symptom but
characteristically people with this
disorder are very very interested in
looks but more importantly they utilize
their looks to get that attention to get
that respect that they're seeking and so
this type of a personality might be
flirtatious with everybody
characteristically they actually
couldn't even be subtly and when I say
flirtatious I'm not talking overtly sexy
but uh kind of inappropriately
flattering sometimes they act in a kind
of a girlish way to be cute and to a
gender attention and this will even
occur in their therapy relationships as
a way to sort of avoid getting negative
feedback or criticism oftentimes they'll
bring the therapist gifts or be destroy
reacting if they engage in therapy
because they just don't want any
criticism they want the therapist to
like them
does the intelligence of the affected
person
bear on the manner in which these
disorders present
excuse me I choked a little of my water
uh
yes and I think one way to think about
it that's probably a little more
accurate than just intelligence is
in Psychology we would describe this
more as sophistication so Street Smart
so to speak
the way for instance I've had many
clients who have borderline personality
disorder
who are
um messy and really clearly suffering
and um they might be difficult and all
over the place and yell at you in the
middle Obsession but it's so uh
uh it's not tailored it's so much easier
to work with because of that just
openness and rawness of it genuineness
sometimes you'll have a more
sophisticated presentation there are
nine symptoms and only five have to be
Mets there are a lot of different
combinations and different ways it can
present and sometimes you'll have more
of a petulant version of this where it
really shows when you push the button
and you're kind of whoa what was that so
somebody who's really productive high
functioning successful and you get to
know them and you think they're
fantastic because they're so interested
in you too and you might not realize it
but they're mimicking you perfectly so
you're really just kind of falling in
love with this new friend who is being
you
um but then all of a sudden uh you know
you say something that they think is
offensive and you can't in even in your
wildest thoughts understand how that
could have offended somebody but their
reaction is so strong that you kind of
buy into it gosh maybe I did say
something offensive and and you feel bad
about it so that sophisticated version
they can be a little bit more calculated
in the way they present they tend to
kind of hit you where it hurts a little
bit more and they can be actually very
very destructive
what conclusions were you able to draw
about Miss heard's sophistication from
her testing
well from her testing and from her
prison presentation she's she was very
likable but her testing in particular
showed that she approached it in a
manner that remember I told you about
those those scales that are pretty neat
she approached it in a manner that very
clearly minimized any psychological
dysfunction not just that but really
presented herself a free of any problems
and she did so in a way that was very
very sophisticated not obvious
by responding to questions that most
people
might not notice would we're trying to
detect that
uh how did you determine that
so that's based on a particular scale on
the mmpi2 that is designed specifically
to detect a type of responding that's a
little bit more clever a little bit more
sophisticated minimizing problems in a
way that most lay people probably
wouldn't unders and even providers very
difficult to detect
you mentioned that one of the
characteristics of borderline
personality disorder is emotional
reactivity
how might that present in an intimate
relationship
so I think it probably presents mostly
or you'd see the bulk of it in Intimate
Relationships because of that regular
interaction and the desire for your
partner to meet all of your needs to be
the perfect caretaker also that
um the Hallmark of the disorder with the
splitting so idealizing devaluing and
the perceiving of all sorts of neutral
events as somehow demeaning or
disrespectful it's
regular escalations of anger frustrated
complaints criticisms of your partner
but because the person with borderline
personality disorder first of all
they're more sensitive to things they
feel distress
more strongly and then that distress
lasts longer so these types of blow-ups
go on forever and they're very cyclic it
feels like you just can't get a
resolution and eventually the partner
will try to leave will want to leave to
take a break it wears them down and
that's when the borderline might explode
and act very aggressively or violently
to try to prevent them from leaving
in
addition to
diagnosing misheard with these two
personality disorders
did you form another another opinion
about Ms heard's mental status
yes so and and not there go ahead
if the answer to that is yes I'm gonna
now ask okay yes I did
okay what is it
so uh in addition to looking for
misheard's General mental status any
psychological issues that were present I
very specifically was assessing to
determine whether post-traumatic stress
disorder was present and it was not how
do you know that
so first of all from uh well from
multiple information sources right so I
was integrating the interview my review
of the data the case records other
people's testimony her treatment records
and then I also conducted in addition to
the mmpi2 and looking at that data I
also conducted the
clinician-administered PTSD scale the
Caps 5 which is the gold standard PTSD
assessment
developed by the national Center for
PTSD shown to be valid accurate for use
not just with service members but also
with civilians men women all genders
and also all ethnicities and then also
specifically for use in a courtroom
setting
how do you conduct the Caps 5
. so the Caps 5 is a standard interview
what that means is that it's an
interview with very clear questions that
are scripted and you ask those same
questions every time you test a person
so because you're doing that you're
actually taking something that would
typically be kind of subjective an
interview with somebody and you're
making it more objective when you ask
those same questions in the same way
every time somebody's assessed with this
now you can apply a scoring protocol and
actually score their responses
okay
as a result of applying those protocols
what did you conclude
Miss heard did not have PTSD and there
were also pretty significant indications
that she was grossly exaggerating
symptoms of PTSD when asked about them
how did you make that latter conclusion
so one of the strengths of this test as
I mentioned the important thing about
any test used when you're doing an
evaluation in forensics is to make sure
that the person is responding accurately
and this test does that by not just
asking people whether they have a
symptom but asking follow-up questions
that draw out very detailed accounts of
every single symptom of PTSD and when
you're really familiar with this
disorder which you need to be to
administer this test
there are nuances in the way a person
will describe their symptoms that have
been shown repeatedly to indicate
exaggeration or faking there are also
indications
when somebody is clearly giving you a
genuine response
what if any symptoms of PTSD Did You
observe and misheard
so there are 20 kind of core symptoms
that somebody might can manifest with
PTSD you don't have to have all of them
Ms hurt initially said that she had in
the first question you say do you ever
have this before you get to the more
nuanced follow-up questions when I asked
that first question on each item she
initially said yes I have that to 19 of
the 20 symptoms
that's not typical even of somebody with
the most disabling form of PTSD
when we eventually sort of dialed it
down she had three remaining symptoms
and having symptoms of any disorder is
common for all of us some of us struggle
with sleep some of us get anxious
um
it could be several different disorders
it could just be that you have this
struggle in your life
but she had three specific symptoms that
I scored as present off the top of my
head I might miss one but one was sleep
disturbance so
um she reported that she has frequent
nightmares another one was that she said
that she tends to have a startle
response so she gets startled or
surprised
she tends to stay in sort of a hyper
startle mode for quite a while and
that's consistent with a couple of
things it can be consistent with PTSD if
other criteria are met it's also
consistent with childhood complex trauma
which is something that can occur when
your brain is forming if you constantly
feel unsafe if your parents are abusive
or if they're not present if you're
neglected you can develop certain
physiological responses that can stay
for a long time in your life so I I
noted that that was seems like a very
genuine accurate account where she stays
in the state of kind of hyper arousal
has a hard time calming down if she gets
surprised
you mentioned nightmares as well yes did
she recount for you the nature of the
nightmares so they were vague she
indicated that she has recurrent
nightmares and that she feels as though
she's being held down
um and there there was some conflict in
that account because even though that
could be a PTSD symptom it is it is
fairly vague but I still scored it as
present
and in her initial treatment with Miss
I'm sorry with Dr Bonnie Jacobs which I
believe started before she began dating
Mr debb she had indicated to Dr Jacobs
according to Dr jacobs's notes that she
was having repetitive nightmares back
then and that they were related to her
childhood trauma and so that came up
several times in the notes Dr Jacobs
kept mentioning that
thank you
what is feigning
feigning is essentially faking or
exaggerating symptoms that aren't
present
does the Caps five control for that
it doesn't necessarily control for it it
can expose it by drawing out how does
that work because you're not just simply
handing the person a checklist that says
here are all the symptoms of PTSD why
don't just check off the ones you have
which clearly if you're trying to look
like you have PTSD you would just check
them all the Caps five because it
requires them to describe in detail how
they experience the symptom where it
shows up what it looks like what sort of
examples they can give you how many
times it's happened in the last couple
weeks how many times it's happened in
the last month
by the end of each symptom you've gotten
a very good picture of a couple things
one does it meet the definition of the
symptom are they getting it right right
is this actually the symptom are they
kind of confusing this with something
else
number two are they giving you very
vague accounts
um are they giving you kind of a
stereotyped idea of what the symptom is
based on Media or movies or something
that actually is completely different
from genuine experiences of this symptom
or are they giving you a very genuine
heartfelt sometimes minimizing but
it's it's ticking all the boxes they're
mannerisms while they're describing it
the uh actual very specific very nuanced
symbolic ways they're describing it a
lot of times
um it smells it sounds that all appears
in genuine accounts and it's something
that people really get wrong when
they're feigning
um
in addition to your conclusion that Miss
heard does not have PTSD did you make a
conclusion with respect to her symptoms
uh Yes actually I did so uh you know
just because somebody doesn't have PTSD
doesn't mean that they weren't harmed
psychologically by whatever is being
alleged in this case Ms hurt is alleging
that she was psychologically harmed in
that she suffered PTSD because of abuse
that she alleges occurred by Mr Depp so
I also the mmpi too is helpful because
it shows you kind of everything any
other symptoms and then a misheard's own
self-report and her prior treatment
records I knew that she had uh reported
to me that uh she had had some other
symptoms so now what becomes really
important is determining and let me
clarify one thing here not so much a
diagnosis
but did she start to experience symptoms
during the relationship and after did
they worsen after or could these types
of symptoms or reports be explained by
other factors a by feigning
B by pre-existing conditions or C by
other stressful life events that might
have occurred
so the main symptoms that I was looking
at didn't meet criteria for PTSD right
there was also you know substantial
evidence of this sort of emotional
dysregulation emotional disorganization
the shallowness the dramatic affect
now when you have a lot of childhood
trauma you can actually have some
similar type presentation in adulthood
there are some differences though but
also that's not something that would
have occurred after this relationship so
now I was looking at are there
indications that these types of things
that she's described this transient
anxiety the issues with sleep were these
there prior
and sure enough misheard in her own
self-report stated to me that when she
first got to La she was seeking
treatment for in her words blanket
anxiety and depression she also reported
that she was taking medications in
general none of them were helpful that's
actually very typical of borderline
personality disorder medications
typically aren't very helpful for
somebody with a disorder they really
need an intensive lifelong type of
therapy which is not necessarily as
relevant to this but interestingly also
people with borderline personality
disorder often respond really positively
to stimulant medications that are given
for add or ADHD and in one of nurse
fellati's notes she reported that Ms
heard told her that none of the
medications were working for her except
for one provisional which is often
prescribed as stimulant medication and I
just thought that was interesting and
sort of consistent with more of these
lifelong personality disorders that
aren't necessarily caused by a harm by
any allegations but have been there and
will remain there typically
the other uh issue you know so the
anxiety she had already indicated that
that had been there prior but the form
of the anxiety so looking at Dr hughes's
testing and then also looking at the
scores on the mmpi when you look at all
these little combinations of the scores
you can actually learn a lot about is
the anxiety related to an event or is
this more a person who tends to be an
anxious person regardless of what's
going on in their life and somebody
might describe them as a worry wart and
the scores the little
combination of scores that she obtained
actually indicated that it was the
latter that her anxiety tends to be
separate from events and more just kind
of a constant and it comes and goes but
it's more of a trait
I have no further questions for this
witness all right
maybe we while we go ahead and um go
ahead and have our lunch break it might
be a good idea to break it up there
okay I know I could see you jumping up
all right uh ladies and Gentlemen let's
go ahead and take our lunch recess just
again do not do any outside research and
don't discuss the case with anybody okay
have you back here
and again Dr Curry since you're in the
middle of your testimony please do not
discuss your testimony with anybody at
this time okay all right that's just
while we come back at 1 50. okay come
back 150 all right thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
one more
you have your seats all right across the
examination you can sit down here
thank you
Dr Curry you're not board certified
correct no I'm not not in Clinical
Psychology or in forensic psychology
correct no I'm a licensed clinical
psychologist but you're not board
certified no okay and you also have only
been practicing approximately eight
years is that correct that's not correct
how many years I've been licensed for 10
years and I've been practicing for about
15 years okay and that includes what you
went through with your different trials
in Hawaii and everything else that you
testified to correct yes okay now you
went to Mr Depp's home for dinner and
drinks
before you were hired as an expert in
this case correct that's not quite what
right I was interviewed at Mr Depp's
home by his legal team dinner was served
you in attendance with Mr Depp was Adam
Waldman correct yes Ben Chu correct yes
Camille Vasquez yes okay and the dinner
lasted approximately three to four hours
correct yes and it includes the
interviews correct yes dinner and I
believe drinks were served okay
okay and this was
correct
yes this was an interview so that they
could make an informed decision as to
whether or not to retain me and don't
you think that's a little odd that
you're getting interviewed by Mr Depp to
decide whether you're going to testify
adversely against Amber Heard
I was interviewed by the legal team
and Mr Depp was present it was his home
correct yes and he was serving dinner
and drinks he was not serving dinner yes
it was at his house at his behest
correct yes it was at his house okay and
you were contacted by Camille Vasquez
somebody you knew in the community in
February of 2020 is that correct I knew
of Ms Vasquez professionally we live in
the same city and I work with many
attorneys
and at that time you not only knew
Johnny Depp you'd seen a number of his
TV and movie roles and you believed he
was a good actor correct not correct I
did not know Johnny Depp you've seen
several of his movies you knew who he
was yes right and you believed he was a
good actor yes
and then you provided an expert
designation in this case before ever
seeing Amber or having an opportunity to
review any documents or records isn't
that correct I did not provide an expert
designation that's that's an attorney
thing my opinions are contained in my
report
plaintiff's exhibit 884 please
foreign
this was plaintiff's designation
identification of expert Witnesses in
this case
and this is dated February 2021 that's a
year after you went to dinner at Mr
Depp's house correct yes okay and it
attributes if you go to page 13 it says
you have three opinions
the first of those is that Amber Heard
quote exhibits patterns of behavior that
are consistent with co-occurring cluster
B personality disorder traits especially
borderline personality disorder did I
get that right
I'm reading that here that is not my
opinion okay well but it's a current
opinion but this was not an opinion of
mine then I didn't have any opinions at
that time it says Dr Curry will testify
correct that's what it says yes okay and
this is a signed pleading correct on
behalf of Mr death I I'm not sure I
understand what that means
we don't understand what a signed
pleading is no okay do you understand
that Mr Depp's Council prepared this and
served it on Ms herd's Council
I I'm not an attorney I don't understand
necessarily all of these procedures okay
are you aware that Mr Depp is on an
audio recording years earlier taunting
Amber Heard that she has a borderline
personality disorder I was made aware of
that in this case yes so you were
actually under the audience not
necessarily It's haunting but I do
recall hearing that Mr Depp had used
that phrase so it's a coincidence that
you now think she has those attributes
after the attorneys listed it in
February 2021 before you'd looked at
anything and Mr death had made that
accusation to misheard years earlier my
opinions aren't based on coincidence
objection I'm sorry doctor yes compound
I'll sustain the objection all right
it's a coincidence then that you came up
with symptoms of borderline personality
disorder years later after Mr Depp has
been taunting Ms heard in an audio tape
I can't speak to whether or not there's
a coincidence but I can tell you is my
opinions are based on the results of my
evaluation and it's a coincidence that
Mr Depp's Council attributed that to you
that said that to you in February 2021
before you'd looked at anything correct
I'm not sure okay now would you agree
that a disproportionate number of women
are tagged with a diagnosis of
borderline personality disorder
no that's not quite right
75 percent
the way you phrase it is not quite right
tell me tell me what's right okay so
there are more women who have been
diagnosed with bipolar disorder than men
it's more prevalent in women
and Trauma can cause borderline
personality disorders can't it no never
right now we know that there are people
who have borderline personality disorder
who have sustained childhood trauma
there are also people who have
borderline personality disorder who have
had no childhood trauma so like most
personality disorders and really like
most mental health issues in general
there seems to be both a biological
component in this case with borderline
personality disorder the research tends
to support a genetic component and
possibly a neurological component and
then there is also possibly an
environmental component triggering those
genetic markers do you know the
percentage of women who are victims of
ipv intimate partner violence or
domestic abuse who are diagnosed with
borderline personality disorders I can't
tell you the percentage off of the top
of my head but I do know that there is a
larger women with borderline personality
disorder tend to have a higher
prevalence of being involved in intimate
partner violence relationships being the
receiver of violence and being the
perpetuators of violence now you've
never been asked to testify or serve as
an expert with respect to whether
someone has a bipolar disorder is that
correct a bipolar disorder yes that's
not correct okay
bear with me
foreign
yes ma'am
thank you
thank you
taken in this case yes on March 21 2022
I believe that was the date yes and were
you under oath at that time yes all
right I'm going to ask you to turn to
page 207.
and the question was have you ever been
asked to testify or serve as an expert
with respect to whether someone has
bipolar disorder and your answer at that
time will you please read to the jury
I'm sorry page 207 207 line five uh
could you know okay thank you
now
when this designation was served in
February of 2021 you had not rendered an
opinion that quote misheard exhibits
patterns of behavior that are consistent
with co-occurring cluster cluster B
personality disorder traits especially
borderline personality disorder correct
I'm sorry I I missed the first part what
was that when this designation was
served that you have in front of you as
plaintiff's exhibit 884 okay
you had not rendered an opinion that
quote misheard exhibits patterns of
behavior that are consistent with
co-occurring cluster B personality
disorder traits especially borderline
personality disorder correct no I had
not rendered any opinions my opinions
weren't finalized until after my
evaluation right so when this came out
you had not rendered that opinion I had
not rendered that opinion okay the
second opinion that's listed in the
February 2021 is that misheard
repeatedly and character illogically
perpetuated severe physical and
psychological intimate partner violence
ipv toward Mr Depp over the course of
their relationship end of quote did I
read that correctly
uh it says perpetrated but other than
that yes okay and so it is it correct
that they that this pleading says in
February 2021 that you are going to
testify to that
this document yes okay it says that and
you have never been asked to testify as
to whether anyone has behaviorally or
characterologically conducted conduct
that suggests they may be an ipv
perpetrator correct
I have I have to ask that again because
I stumbled I can't think character
logically that one's just a tough one
for me okay you have never been asked to
testify as to whether anyone has
Behavioral or character logical conduct
that suggests they may have been an ipv
perpetrator correct no I've never been
asked to testify for that okay and that
was not your opinion in February 2021
correct no and in fact you do not hold
that opinion now and you were not even
asked to provide such an analysis or
opinion isn't that correct no or that is
correct that's correct okay
and you have never held that opinion
correct
no that is correct yes okay
and your third opinion if we can go to
page 14
was it misheard exhibits patterns of
behavior that suggest her allegations of
abuse against Mr Depp are false end of
quote do you see that
I see that you said it's my third
opinion that is not my opinion
all right but in this pleading it says
that you will testify to that correct
yes that's what this says okay and that
was not your opinion in February 2021
was it no as I said I had not formed any
opinions at that time I had just been
retained
and in fact you have never arrived at
this opinion as an expert witness in
this case correct
in terms of the opinions that I've
rendered are provided in my report and
you hear what I'm testifying to today
and you have never arrived at this
opinion as an expert witness in this
case correct
I'll sustainable you have never arrived
at the opinion that misheard exhibits
patterns of behavior that suggest for
allegations of abuse against Mr Depp are
false correct
that's correct okay
okay and in fact you've said that has
never been my opinion correct
what I'm saying is that this the
opinions in here I these are not my
opinions my opinions are provided in my
report can you please turn to page 255
of your deposition
and if we can start on 254 to give I
don't have that page I'm sorry 254 line
11. oh okay
and the question is now the next one is
quote misheard exhibits patterns of
behavior that suggest her allegations of
abuse against Mr dab are false end of
quote was that your opinion in February
2021 and you answered at that time no
correct
that is correct and then I asked have
you ever arrived at that opinion in the
time that you have served as an expert
witness in this case
and your answer was could you read that
to the jury please yes
um so no it's not the task
I was cut off or I
essentially what I read I what I said
then was that you're not the task of
Dash that was never my task to determine
can I say what that means no and then
the question is so is it fair to say
that you have never arrived at an
opinion that quote Ms heard exhibits
patterns of behavior that suggest
allegations of abuse against Mr Depp are
false end of quote and what was your
answer
well there is an objection all right
I'll I'll read it for you if you're
having difficult your answer was under
oath correct that is not my opinion that
has never been my opinion isn't that
where it said on growth on March 21st
okay
and then I wrote do then I'm going to
ask you do you know who wrote this
portion of the designation suggesting
that these were your opinions in
February of 2021
and what was your answer I said no
no
expert designation
any materials reach any opinions correct
I believe I had just started to review
materials I I believed that I indicated
that in my deposition I had not yet
rendered any opinions I
how to completed my review and I hadn't
conducted an evaluation okay
and in fact you've never testified as an
expert on ipv intimate partner violence
isn't that correct
I believe that is correct but I may not
be remembering all of my cases so let's
go to page 200 okay
line 17
my question was have you ever testified
as an expert on ipv and your answer
under oath then at line 22 was what
oh gosh let me catch up line 22.
no
and you've never testified as an expert
on emotional distress damages associated
with ipv is that correct that's correct
okay and you've never been asked to
testify with respect to emotional
damages associated with domestic
violence or abuse isn't that correct
uh again that
I'm reluctant to say that's correct
because with 15 years of experiences
I'll experience a lot of my cases have
been complex and that may have been a
component but I don't remember
explicitly a case being just about that
let's go to page 199 line 20.
my question to you was have you ever
been asked to testify with respect to
emotional damages associated with
domestic violence or abuse
and your answer under oath at that time
was
no
I've not right sorry on the page in time
okay you said no I've not but I have not
okay
now you also have never been asked to
testify on whether an individual is
being truthful in saying that they are a
survivor of ipv is that correct
that's correct okay and you have never
qualified as an expert to speak to
whether a person suffered from ipv
intimate partner violence or was a
victim or Survivor of ipv is that
correct
that's outside of the task of a
psychologist
to determine whether an event occurred
we assess Behavior we we assess mental
status we don't detect crimes
so you have not been asked to testify to
that correct it's not something that
occurs so no I have not and you were not
ultimately asked to provide any opinions
on that correct no I was not okay now
you did not disclose in any of the
designations or your report that you had
met with and had dinner and drinks with
Mr Depp did you
I'm sorry can you repeat that one more
time that you did not disclose in any of
the designations or in your report
[Music]
Mr death correct I did not disclose that
I was interviewed by the legal team no
I asked a different question
are you trying to resist that you didn't
have dinner with Mr Depp and drinks I'm
not trying to resist that but it's not
quite right
you did your dinner with Mr Depp did you
not I did
that did you not
and what you had drinks with Mr Depp did
you know drinks were served I this was
over two years ago I may have had a
drink with dinner yes
in fact you thought you had a mule
something right possibly yes okay and
you didn't disclose that you had met
with Mr dap Mr Waldman Mr Chu and Ms
Vasquez at Mr Depp's house for three to
four hours and had dinner and drinks
correct I did not disclose that it's not
significant to the report
you don't think that's significant
correct I don't okay but you've never
been asked to meet with a client in his
Council before being retained as an
expert either before or after have you
no and you've Justified that it was okay
in this case because it was a high
profile case that's not quite right I
Justified it in this case actually I
sought consultation about it first of
all the person who had retained his
attorneys was unable to come to my
office with his attorneys and yes this
is a very visible case it's been going
on a very long time and I understood
that there would be a need to interview
me and determine make an informed
decision about my qualifications
can you look at page 240 please
line three is my question would you
agree it's a highly irregular to meet
with the subject in a litigation
and your answer on that occasion was I
would not say it's highly irregular I
would say it's not something that I
would typically do however I had not yet
been retained on the case this was a
large high-profile case and I understood
that I believe that it was appropriate
for a person retaining me with such a
high profile to meet me to be able to
vet me essentially with the attorneys
present prior to retaining me on his
case do you recall that yes that's what
you said under oath correct yes and then
I said have you ever done that before
and you said no correct and then I said
have you ever done it since and you said
no correct correct okay
now
would you agree that if you did not find
something that would be in favor of Mr
Depp and a negative to Ms heard that you
wouldn't be an expert in this case
essentially into court if you're going
to say that hurt is right Mr Depp is
wrong so as a forensic psychologist my
obligation is to the court is to the
fact finder I present science regardless
of what that science may be now when I
take a case my retainer agreement is
explicit about that nice yes
I'm asking you a question I'd like you
to try to answer one question you
understand that if you found favorably
to misheard and negatively to Mr Depp
you wouldn't be here right you wouldn't
be testifying object inspective no I
okay sorry hold on objection speculation
I I that's that's not speculation no
I'll sustain the objection if you want
to ask okay
if
it goes to bias your honor it's just any
objection next question all right
you were in fact so excited about being
involved in this case that you told your
husband even though this was a highly
confidential matter that you were going
to be conducting the examination of Ms
heard didn't you that is not accurate
you not only told your husband but you
told Ms heard that you told your husband
correct
Miss Brett Huff that is not accurate
what is accurate
you're incorrect that is not correct is
your testimony today under oath that you
did not tell your husband that you were
going to be conducting the examination
of Amber that is my testimony
okay
let's go to page 306
foreign
so the question that was asked was
because you brought muffins you said
from your husband right you get and you
gave those to miss heard correct
may I clarify what occurred so that we
can stop talking about the muffins what
happened was that I was getting ready
that morning I frequently bring muffins
to the office my husband did happen to
know that there was going to be a
celebrity client coming in because on
the mornings that that occurs which
often occurs we have to actually clear
the office and move the staff to the
other office so yes on the one hand he
was aware of that I was getting ready I
asked him to go to the bakery near our
house and pick up the muffins for me
because I was running late he often has
to do that because I often do run late
he brought the muffins back to the house
I brought them into the office Miss hurt
and I enjoyed the muffins together I
think I made a comment to her along the
lines like we can thank my husband he
brought or my husband got these for us
today meaning he purchased the muffins
we are now enjoying them because of him
did you say on pages 305 and 306 that
you frequently have examinations of high
profile clients you want to just take a
quick look and tell us
what 305 306 yeah that's where we're
talking about it is there a line you'd
like me to look at you can start with uh
15. line 15 305. just read through that
and tell me whether you said anywhere in
there that you have a lot of high
profile examinations you do this
frequently
I don't agree I want to approach please
so
why did your husband get the muffins for
Amber Heard
he did not get the muffins for Amber
Heard
he knew you had a high-profile client
and he was and you were preparing for a
very long time and you asked him to pick
up the muffins correct I asked him to
pick up the muffins for me yes okay
now would you agree that domestic abuse
can be verbal
absolutely yes would you agree that
domestic abuse can be emotional yes
certainly would you agree that domestic
abuse can be psychological yes would you
agree that domestic abuse can be
physical yes
now you indicated and I believe you
testified in your direct that it's very
important to review the treatment
records before forming opinions is that
correct yes okay in fact that's the
first thing you would do correct
not necessarily the first but it's part
of the evaluation
let's go to page 261
and let's go to 260 because that's where
I start the question
the question I asked was and do you
recall whether you'd review any of these
by the designation on February 19 2021
and you said okay I can't say for
certain what I can tell you is that
knowing my normal procedure I would have
reviewed the treatment records first did
you testify to that under oath then yes
okay now before we start getting into
the ones that you testified about I just
want to be
you actually uh
have as an opinion with respect to the
borderline personality disorder and the
histrionics you didn't diagnose you
didn't actually have a DSM-5 diagnosis
that Amber Heard suffers from either
borderline personality disorder or
histrionic personality disorder correct
that's not correct you're in fact your
report
says misheard demonstrates
psychological symptoms
of a combined borderline and histrionic
personality disorder would you agree yes
I did say that in also what designation
was that I believe January
18th that report was included
yes okay and that's what you said at
that time correct yes okay I said a
little bit more than that as well
you said and I'll read it I'll quote it
quote based on the combined results of
my interview with Ms heard behavioral
observations
psychometric test data and review of the
available records misheard demonstrates
psychological symptoms
of a combined borderline and histrionic
personality disorder bhpd that's what
you wrote in your report as one of your
conclusions and that's a DSM-5 diagnosis
and it did not say that you were
diagnosing with a DSM-5 for borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder did it that's what
it says in different semantics
I did not use the words you just said
that you said that you reviewed but I'm
going to start with Rocky Pennington
your testimony was that out of the blue
Amber hit Rocky Pennington correct
I can't remember exactly what I said but
I did reference Miss Pennington's
deposition that misheard struck Miss
Pennington in the face in fact Ms
Pennington testified that she hit Ms
heard and in response to that she can't
recall but misheard either pushed or
slapped her correct
I don't recall
that's a pretty important distinction
don't you think
my recollection is that there was some
sort of violence both ways in the
relationship either way it seems that
both of them might have been unstable
I'm only evaluating miss her so so now
we have an evaluation of Rocky
Pennington no I just said but that was
not relevant to my opinion because I'm
only evaluating this hard but you
testified to that undirected that was a
factor right yes okay well wouldn't it
make a big difference if Amber struck
first or just responded back
given the dynamic not necessarily no it
would not have so so now you're an
expert on Rocky Pennington and her
Dynamics with Amber hurt
um okay so now let's talk about Dr Cowan
you not only reviewed his treatment
records and his text messages and
documents but you also attended his
deposition did you not yes okay and do
you recall Dr Cohen testifying that
Amber told him about depth physically
abusing her contemporaneous with the
events
I don't recall specifically his words
but I remember him recalling that she
had disclosed abuse in their treatment
yes and do you recall Dr Cowan
testifying that he received a text
message contemporaneous uh that Johnny
did a number on me tonight I'm safe in
my support tonight but I need some real
help do you remember him testifying to
that I don't remember the testimony but
I do remember seeing that text message
as one of the exhibits and do you
remember Dr Cowan testified that on
another occasion Amber sent him a text
Johnny beat me up pretty good last night
end of quote again
not in this constant she she can rely on
it
thank you thank you I didn't need to
argue that hard I guess do you recall
that again I don't recall the testimony
but I do remember that being an exhibit
I've seen it do you recall Dr Cowan
testifying that not only did he believe
Amber in her reporting of the abuse by
Deb but that she had no ulterior motive
I actually don't recall that I'm not
saying that it didn't occur okay do you
recall Dr Cowan testifying that he
believed the relationship was toxic and
he was concerned for Amber's physical
well-being
I do recall him saying that he believed
the relationship was toxic
you don't recall I do not know in saying
that he was concerned for Amber's
physical well-being I don't remember
those exact words
do you believe do you recall Dr Cowan
testifying in that deposition that you
were present for referring to Mr Depp
quote his controlling nature jealousy
and suspiciousness addiction to drugs
and alcohol and violent and indulgent
temper do you recall him using those
terms to describe Mr Depp I remember
thinking that would be an inappropriate
impression for a treating provider of a
different person to give but I do recall
him making that statement
do you recall Dr Cohen testifying that
if he pushed her she was going to push
him back and I never had the impression
that she was the provocateur but that
she was indicating to me she had a hard
time you know de-escalating these types
of situations yes okay and do you also
recall him saying that she didn't say
she pushed him she just said I got right
back up he told me that she told me that
he pushed her down and she got back
right back up
I remember him saying that Ms heard told
him that yes and do you recall him
testifying you could interpret it that
way I kind of interpret it more you know
metaphorically that when somebody comes
at her she goes back at them you know in
a similar way whether it's verbally or
she protects herself
uh I I may I recall something along
those lines but it was a six or seven
hour deposition so the specifics are not
fresh in my mind do you recall Dr Cowan
specifically testifying that he believed
Amber Heard when she reported the
physical abuse by Mr Depp I recall him
saying that and following it up with a
statement that you have to take the
patient at their word when you're the
therapist
you recall that yes
do you recall him saying he took her
that he believed her that he found her
believer yes yes that he found her
believable okay
um now you also testify about Amy Banks
do you recall that yes and before we go
there Dr Cohen has been a clinical
psychologist for 40 years correct
I'm not sure okay well he testified to
that didn't he in the deposition I don't
recall and he also saw Amber Heard for
over two years correct
yes from 2014 approximately August 2014
to 2000 through 2016. correct yes he did
for a period of time would you agree
okay and he also testified that he did
not diagnose Amber with borderline
personality disorder do you recall that
testimony he also testified that he
doesn't use diagnoses but yes I do
recall that and do you recall that it
was in those words were in his notes
but he said he had written that down but
then he discounted and determined that
that was not correct for her
are you on approach
all right now let's jump to Amy Banks Dr
Banks is a psychiatrist correct correct
yes in fact she went to Medical School
Georgetown and she did her psychiatric
training at Harvard Medical School
correct I believe that's correct I don't
recall 100 all right and she was a
psychiatrist in Massachusetts that Amber
Heard had reached out to yes after the
Australia incident to try to help her
relationship with Mr Depp correct
I
let me back up you attended Dr Banks
deposition as well did you not yes I did
and Dr Banks testified to that correct
uh I don't remember if she testified to
that I don't have the notes right in
front of me or the deposition transcript
you recall Dr Banks testifying
that she understood that Amber was in a
relationship with Johnny Depp that had
gotten violent and out of control
I I don't recall specifically no do you
recall Amy Banks testifying that they
had physical altercations and his drug
use had escalated and Amber felt she was
at risk
I don't recall
do you recall Amy Banks testifying that
Amber was reporting the Violence by Mr
Depp and it was not consensual
I recall Dr Banks stating that Ms heard
was reporting violence to her yes I do
not recall a statement about
consent
do you recall
Dr Banks testifying
that there was discussion about Mr Depp
cutting off his finger and she said only
that it was a middle of one of these
very con kind of out of control
escalated fights and that did make a
fairly big impact on me
I remember something like that all right
and do you recall that Dr Banks saying
it was a whole other level as I remember
it told to me he actually cut off a part
of his finger during one of these
altercations meaning to me the way I
digested that if you will was that
things had gotten particularly out of
control
I do not recall that exact statement I'm
not saying it didn't occur I just can't
recall it all right
call that Mr Depp was
with Dr Banks correct I yes my
understanding however is that they met
with Dr Banks and then it was primarily
misheard meeting with Dr Banks for
treatment after prescriptions and
therapy all right and do you recall Dr
Banks saying that she was not surprised
that Amber was seeking a restraining
order because of the violence that she
knew existed in the relationship
I do recall that and it would be
impossible to know that violence exists
as a treating therapist or as a
psychologist again we're not
investigators however I do recall that
she said that because I remember having
that thought
and do you recall Amy and she's a
psychiatrist right psychiatrist okay and
do you recall Amy Banks saying that it
was clear to her that Mr Depp was the
one who initiated the violence I don't
recall that
all right do you recall
that Dr Banks said that she knew for
certain
that Mr Depp was the one who who had
committed the violence because Ms heard
reported it in the presence of Mr Depp
and he did not contradict I do not
recall that okay
and do you recall that Dr Banks
ultimately concluded that it was her
belief that Amber was a victim of
domestic violence at the hands of Mr
death
there you want to approach this
and what was your answer to that last
one I'm sorry
I think I can't recall but I also can't
recall that last question do you recall
that Dr Banks concluded that Amber was a
victim of domestic violence at the hands
of Mr Depp I don't recall that
okay
now
you also reviewed the records of Laurel
Anderson and you reviewed her deposition
is that correct
um Let me refresh my memory for a moment
uh
um I reviewed Dr Anderson's deposition
yes okay and do you recall that she
reported that that Amber Heard had had
reported physical violence by Mr Depp to
her I recall that she said that Ms heard
had reported that yes okay and do you
recall that she said that it changed
over time
I don't recall that specifically
well Dr Andrew
face being bruised
Bruce December 15 2015 incident I don't
recall that you don't recall that okay
um
and do you recall
that Dr Anderson said that Amber had
reported that uh he had pulled out her
hair bruised her face kicked her leg and
hit her in the head yes Miss heard did
report that to her according to her
testimony okay and do you recall that
Amber Heard said that Mr debb was
scaring her
I don't recall that specifically okay
and do you recall that Dr Anderson said
she believed that Amber Heard was a
victim of domestic abuse at the hands of
Mr death
I recall uh no I don't recall that
statement
all right let's go to Bonnie Jacobs
you said that you reviewed the notes
from Bonnie Jacobs correct
yes
and what you testified to
was that you discounted these because
the first notes from Bonnie Jacobs
indicated that she already had all of
these symptoms correct just I'm sorry I
don't understand what you're saying I
discounted tell me why you discounted
Bonnie Jacobs notes I did not discount
Bonnie Jacobs notes
you said that she the Bonnie Jacobs in
her notes had already determined that
these symptoms were present for Amber
Heard before the relationship with Mr
Depp did you not
what I recall saying was that within Dr
jacobs's notes she's documented
instances in which Ms heard reported to
her over the course of therapy that she
was experiencing nightmares recurrent
nightmares in fact about childhood abuse
okay now the very first
entry on Bonnie Jacob's notes and these
are the notes right do you recognize
these I do and we received more uh sort
of at the tail end just a couple months
ago all right so the first of Bonnie
Jacobs notes is on 1017 2011. do you
recall that I I don't recall the exact
date I don't have anything in front of
me and she was already Amber Heard was
already in the relationship with Johnny
Depp at this point was she not
I believe she was yes okay and in Bonnie
Jacob's notes she documents however oh
go ahead she documents multiple multiple
occasions that Amber Heard reports to
her physical violence upon her by Mr
Depp does she not
there are several notes that indicate
that Ms hurt is reported Violence by Mr
Depp yes many many correct
I wouldn't qualify it as many many
I'm not sure what you mean by money how
many would you say I don't know I don't
have the notes in front of me okay well
what do you recall in deciding to make
your opinions in this case well I'm
confused about the dates because I know
that Dr Jacobs treated Miss hurt even
while she was in her prior relationship
leaving her prior relationship with her
last wife and Dr Curry I'm not going to
ask you to try to bring in extraneous
things I'm asking you what you recall of
these but the dates would have been
different based on that alone okay and I
recalled that there was quite a bit of
information because these were copious
notes spanning back in time from her
relationship with Tasha Dr Curry please
answer my question how many occasions do
you recall doctor I don't know Dr Jacobs
documenting Amber reporting physical
abuse I don't know
foreign
now you also said that you listened to
audio tapes in this case correct
yes did you hear Mr Depp admitting to
head-butting Ms heard
that is not what I heard you didn't hear
that I heard a conversation about
headbutting I did not hear him as you
said admit to headbutty misheard okay
that's your characterization of it
correct yes okay
um did you see the videotape of Mr Depp
in the kitchen yes okay did Ms heard
imagine that or create that or was she
responsible for that somehow
I'll sustain the objection next question
okay
um
what if any impact did you have did that
have on your opinions watching Mr Depp
in that video
I'm not sure it
it was one of many
pieces of the exhibits and other
collateral data that I considered I'm
not sure what the direct impact was or
if that could be measured all right now
Council asked you whether you had
conducted any type of examination on Mr
Depp and I believe your answer was no
correct no you did not review any
medical records or psychological records
from Mr Depp either did you
I reviewed all of the records that were
available do you recall reviewing
medical and psychological records
yes do you recall Dr Blaustein referring
to Mr Depp having rage
no I actually recall him referring to
misheard in that note
your testimony is that Dr bloustein was
referring to Amber Heard as having rage
I transcribed several of the notes and I
may be missing a time when he
I said that about Mr Depp the
handwriting was very difficult to
transcribe but there was one instance in
which I recall transcribing him
stating that Mr Depp reported that Ms
heard had rage
Dr bloustein's deposition was taken was
it not
I
don't recall do you recall so I'd take
it then you don't recall him testifying
that Mr Depp told him he had rage and
demons I don't recall
do you recall Dr bloustein testifying
that Mr Depp
looked at his wife Amber like his mother
or his sister that he didn't like I
haven't seen his deposition I don't
recall that okay
now did you see and do you know whether
Mr Depp has ever been diagnosed with any
personality disorders
my that's not relevant to my task to
conduct an evaluation of misheard I do
not know that he has had one it was not
in the records that he did all right so
one way or the other you don't know
whether Mr Depp suffers from any
personality disorders
there was that's not my task okay
okay perpetrators would you agree
that accusations of infidelity can be
considered one of the characteristics of
a personality perpetrator of ipv
it can be a characteristic of a lot of
things it is something that can be
weaponized if somebody is trying to or
is having rage toward their partner
let's go to page 270.
line three my question was are
accusations of infidelity considered one
of the characteristics of a perpetrator
or personality perpetrator of ipv
the objection
the question is is vague and ultimately
ambiguous
I I don't understand the objection all
over all the objection and your answer
can you remind me of the page I Thought
page 270 line three was where my
question was okay and your answer is at
line eight
you said it can be correct yes okay and
interrogating your partner about
unfounded accusations of infidelity can
be abusive would you agree
it can be if they're unfounded yes okay
um and
psychological consequences for a victim
of ipv can include diminished
self-esteem correct yes depressed mood
yes anxiety
yes fearfulness certainly diminished
self-agency
yes feeling powerless
yes loss of sleep
yes an ipv is a traumatic stressor would
you agree it is right and ipv is capable
of resulting in PTSD is it not it is
okay and ipv is capable of resulting in
other trauma-based disorders correct
uh
yes okay
now
Amber's medical examination she was
cooperative correct
her psychology yes she was cooperative
and polite okay and and in the twofold
days of examination you felt she was
polite and answered all your questions
except in one instance where she
furrowed her brow when you were asking
about friendships in high school correct
that's not correct all right let's go to
page 275.
so we start on 274 with the was she
polite you said yes what's your
Cooperative yes
um did you answer your questions for the
most part yes this is uh now we're on
page 275 lines four and five and then my
question was did she at any time become
combat combative or unfriendly with you
or angry and your answer was there was
one instance in which she appeared
annoyed and the posturing forward a bit
more assertive tone furrowed brow when I
was questioning something following up
on data that had been inconsistent about
friendships in high school other than
that she was very polite is that your
answer at that time that was my answer
at that time and it's inconsistent with
the question you had just asked me and
would you agree that appearing for this
examination with an expert who had been
retained by Mr Depp more than a year
earlier might be a little stressful
yes okay
okay and in fact not only had you been
retained by Mr Depp but what had been
communicated by Mr Depp's team was that
you had called Amber Heard a liar and a
perpetrator of abuse correct first of
all I I'd like to clarify that I was not
retained by Mr Depp I was retained by Mr
Depp's Council and what I can say that
yes any examinee in a forensic context
you would consider that they're probably
stressed
all right would you agree
that all perpetrators of ipv have anger
management issues
yes
and a large portion of ipv perpetrators
have substance abuse issues
it's one of many factors that correlates
with intimate partner violence but there
are certainly many people who perpetuate
intimate partner violence who do not
have substance abuse issues let's go to
131
line 17.
131 you said
yes
12 is what I have here
and I'm talking about you said and just
to give context remember I was asking
you how many what percentage of uh
people you treat that are perpetrators
and you'd said five percent do you
recall that just for substance
I see that here okay and then I S then I
said
um of the five percent that are ipv
perpetrators that you've treated over
the last eight years how many of these
perpetrators have substance abuse issues
and your answer was
I see that I answered with a figure of
speech a large portion okay thank you
and it's common for the perpetrator to
essentially Gaslight the victim accuse
them of being the perpetrator would you
agree in a different area or are you
asking me I'm asking you a question oh
sorry can you please repeat it yes and
it's common for the perpetrator to
essentially Gaslight the victim accuse
them of being the perpetrator would you
agree
that's exactly how I was asked on the
deposition Zone I understand it is a
compound question though okay objection
and it's common for the perpetrator to
essentially Gaslight I don't think
that's your honor it's just I think it's
just one question
um let me try it to Gaslight the victim
isn't it that's a characteristic of
psychological abuse yes okay and and
common then for them to accuse them of
being the perpetrator the victim that's
a characteristic of abuse from women
perpetrated against men it's actually
very very common about 90 of male
victims of ipv have reported that a
female partner who abuses them makes
threats to uh report their partner as an
abuser it's less common for men to make
that statement to female Partners just
because there's less potential
consequence but isn't it true though
that some form of gaslighting is often
present in these personality-based ipv
scenarios
yes okay
and it's distressing for the victim to
be accused is it not absolutely it
causes them a lot of fear
certainly
and it causes them a lot of distress
absolutely yes and in fact they feel
falsely accused correct yes and they
feel paranoid yes and they feel
frightened yes afraid that everyone's
going to believe the perpetrator correct
yes and in fact they're afraid they're
going to lose their security correct
can you clarify what you mean by
security I'll ask the next one and
they're afraid they're going to lose
their reputation yes
okay
now let's talk about the testing for a
moment
you
talked about the mmpi too but that's not
the most recent mmpi is it no it's the
most researched okay now
you
you need to have an elevated on the mmpi
there was only one section that had
elevated uh elevated scores correct
no that's not correct it was the K
section correct
that's not correct okay and
was there any elevated score over 65 on
the mmpi
I would need to take a look at it if you
know I provided a 25-page interpretation
outline if you're able to pull that up
I'd be happy to go over any of the
individual scores for you can you recall
any clinical scales for the MMP pi2 for
Amber Heard that were above 65 as you
said there today again there are
multiple multiple scales on this test 25
Pages worth listed so if you can pull it
up then I can review and give you a
confident answer
what can you recall as you sit there
I I'm hesitant to do that because I
don't want to make an error By ignoring
hundreds of scale scores and would you
agree that you can't make a pathological
determination or diagnosis if the scales
are not elevated on the mmpi too I would
not agree with that okay
okay one of the answers that
gave
is that it's hard for her to feel safe
correct
what are we are you talking about the
mmpi too
again I don't recall there are 567 items
on that I would need to see her results
well it's a common trauma symptom isn't
it to not feel safe sure and safety
concerns are common among women who have
been victimized correct
women and men yes okay and common
especially for sexually victimized
people would you agree any any type of
victimization yes okay and hard to trust
that's a common after effect of
interpersonal violence related trauma
correct sure
and memory difficulties Amber said she
felt she had holes
do you recall that I do and her account
was different than typical memory
difficulties with drama it is common for
individuals who have experienced it and
it's actually not common no it's a
symptom but it's the least common
in fact a DSM-5 diagnosis for PTSD
includes a quote inability to remember
an important aspect of the traumatic
event end of quote am I correct yes okay
and memory difficulties are a symptom of
PTSD correct
certain types of memory difficulties yes
okay
now do you recall when Amber says the
first incident of abuse took place
I believe it was oh the first incident
in which she yes so she stated that it
was early on in their relationship
do you recall it I don't recall the
exact date off the top of my head do you
recall it being a tattoo something
related to a tattoo I do okay now if
someone had been subjected to a
four-year relationship characterized by
repeated ipv they can have symptoms
correct yes intense anxiety
yes certainly depressed or irritable
States
actually this it's not so much states
when you're looking at a real trauma
reaction it's pretty uh persistent it's
less of these transient States intimate
problems yes relationship difficulties
yes
and these are symptoms you're also
attributing to the personality disorder
correct yes there are some key
differences okay
now let's talk for a moment specifically
about a couple of the profiles on the
mmpi
this is not an exaggerated profile for
her is it
no actually that was something unique
when she completed objective Broadband
measures where the questions you don't
know what the questions are getting at
they seem completely random she raised
scores that indicated that she was
trying to minimize any mental issues and
and appear completely free of pathology
when she took tests that asked questions
that were specific to trauma that's when
you'd see these extreme exaggerations
all right let's go to page 337.
foreign
on line seven this is not an exaggerated
profile is it for her
and your answer under oath at that time
was no it is not an exaggerated profile
do you see that yes they're talking
about the Mii here you testified under
oath at that time correct yes that's
correct now the profile is also not
consistent with malingering correct
the mmpi2 profile it's specific to how
she approached this test and you're
correct for this test it was a defensive
profile not an exaggerated profile
so my question on line 10 was this is
not a profile consistent with
malingering correct and your answer
under oath at that time was correct on
this test it is not consistent with
malindri period right yeah that was your
full answer
okay
now is it your testimony under oath
today that you have not been asked
to testify concerning Ms herd's behavior
in the context of her relationship with
Mr Depp including any abuse
that's correct okay
and you have not made any determinations
including any of opinions that Ms Ms
heard abused Mr Depp or Mr Depp abused
misheard correct correct that's outside
of the scope of psychology okay and you
cannot testify whether Amber Heard
suffered any emotional distress as a
result of any of the defamatory comments
that she has alleged Mr Waldman made
through Mr Mr Depp made through Mr
Waldman correct what I can testify is
that there was no indication of a
decline in psychological functioning
showing any injury since she's been with
Mr Depp
you you cannot testify one way or the
other on that correct
your honor may we approach okay
Dr Curry yes in your report nowhere in
your report would you
provide any opinion of whether Miss
heard suffered emotional distress as a
result of the defamatory statements is
that correct that's correct okay thank
you I have no further questions all
right redirect
Dr Kerr you were just asked a question
about
malingering yes and made reference to
the mmpi to is there another test that
you did to make a determination with
respect to malingering yes so I also
well malingering is a term that I most
psychologists we try to be careful of it
because it indicates an intent for
secondary gain I prefer feigning which
you had brought up earlier because it
indicates that somebody is intentionally
exaggerating but I don't know
necessarily why so I think that's a more
accurate term in General on the mmpi2
yes there was no exaggerated profile I
also gave her though the Caps five I
don't know if you'll remember but that
is the clinician-administered PTSD scale
consistent with the DSM-5 and on that
there were signs of gross exaggeration I
also looked at the test results that
were provided by Dr Hughes and on an
objective test of trauma
there is a scale specific to intentional
exaggeration on that test and misheard
was in the 98th profile 98th percentile
meaning that she is uh
she indicate
she had engaged in extreme levels of
exaggeration
thank you
you were asked about
intimacy problems relationship
difficulties associated
with ipv and and you then said that
there were some key differences yes what
are those
so what you see when we're talking about
the personality disorders is there is a
very consistent pattern of the
aggression the violence the irritability
first of all it's escalated but second
of all it occurs when there is either
for the borderline component a threat of
Abandonment a perceived slight feeling
like the person is about to leave you
about to walk away to get some space
from an argument
it's all it also occurs to a more mild
extent but when there's a loss of
attention and a need to manipulate to
try to get that attention back but it's
not when somebody has PTSD that
irritability is sort of at a low
constant level or it's completely random
for instance you might have a Vietnam
vet who went straight to bars for a
period to get into fights with the hope
that he would kill somebody and just
self-destruct so it's a very different
type of presentation ipv it might be
more irritability but that's actually
less of a symptom for female ipv victims
usually what you'll see is somatic
symptoms the depression a lot of
fearfulness and anxiety but typically
more complaints about somatic symptoms
okay
you testified that some
of the professionals involved this case
had to take their patient at her word
what did you mean by that
so when you're providing therapy you're
in a very different role than an
examiner when you're the forensic
examiner you're just really looking at
data to make a decision when you're a
therapist you're an advocate for your
clients well-being and in fact it's
considered extremely unethical for a
treating provider to ever provide
opinion testimony like I'm providing
because it's so well known in our field
that you're going to have an automatic
bias for your client it's almost a sense
of protection advocacy wanting their
best which is why we also know that it's
a very inappropriate to
convey any sort of opinion about whether
a crime occurred whether abuse occurred
we can certainly believe our clients we
can support them in their therapy and
take them at their word but when giving
opinions and consultations we have to be
very very cautious and really only
provide the the facts we would state
things in terms of my client did report
support this I saw this here was our
treatment plan here was the diagnosis
it's uh we just we're taught we're
trained to stay away from making any
sort of opinions understanding that most
of the time and most of Ms herds
providers were just treating misheard
they had never so much as done an
initial evalu or initial interview with
Mr Depp and gotten his whole life story
or his symptoms or his side of any of it
and they're going to be advocating and
and the treatment relationship is about
helping your client achieve well-being
not making formal psychological or
psychiatric opinions so you're asked a
question about a series of doctors Dr
Cohen treating physician yes he was a
psychologist yeah Dr Banks training
physician Dr Banks yes treating
psychiatrist Dr Anderson
yes uh treating psychologists every one
of them had to take Amber where did
Andrew heard his word right yes
thank you no further questions all right
is this witness subject
that's right uh is this what is subject
to recall
all right since you're subject to recall
Dr Curry please do not uh discuss your
testimony with anybody please do not
watch uh anything of this card okay all
right thank you thank you you could stay
there for a moment okay all right ladies
Jim we'll go ahead and take our
afternoon recess for 15 minutes do not
do any outside research and don't talk
to anybody okay
all right let's go ahead and take our
recess until 3 20 your next Witnesses by
deposition is that correct we will get
you all set up then all right thank you
oh okay we'll come back at 3 20 before
the jury comes back out we'll discuss
your exhibits okay all right thank you
are they agreed on
thank you
thank you
all right ready for the jury then
oh
all right thank you your next Witness
uh we call officer Melissa Signs by
deposition designation and just so the
jury is aware uh for the first hour so
what you'll hear is questioning by Ms
herds Council uh it will then shift to
questioning by Mr gaps Council right
thank you
please state your name and your business
address
um officer Melissa signs
1546 West Martin Luther King Jr
Boulevard Los Angeles California
and what is your occupation
I am a police officer
how long have you been a police officer
going on 12 years
when what year did you begin as a police
officer
2009.
and was that with the LAPD
yes it was
did you have any law enforcement
experience prior to coming to the LAPD
in July of 2009.
no I did not as of May 21 2016 what was
your rank
can you repeat the date
May 21st 2016.
I was a training officer
and was that a P3
correct
and as a training officer were you
considered a field training officer
right
and for how long a period of time had
you been a training officer as of May 21
2016.
approximately
I believe four months
and
who was the first officer you trained
once you became a training officer at
the LAPD
I don't recall
when did you start training officer
Hadden
I I don't recall the exact month
do you have an approximate
uh if the incident was in May that it's
going to be within
two months of May before or after
so are you suggesting that you may not
have started training officer hadn't
until two months after the May 21 2016
incident so he wasn't there
no I'm not was it two months or less
from the time you started training
officer hadn't before the May 21 2016
incident
yes so I have a probationer for two
months
so may could have been the second month
I had them or the first month I had them
but you don't recall as you sit here
today
and training officer
of 2016 incident correct what does
Central Division include
they Encompass downtown Los Angeles
in May of 2016
what shift were you on
I was working nights
what what would the night shift entail
what was the time from when to when
it is approximately
6 45 pm to 6 45 AM
and how many days a week would you work
the shift
usually three days a week
typically what was the range of
evidence that we're working on your
shift in May 2016 in Central Division
I I don't recall I mean are we talking
less than five more than ten more than
25
there would be at least five units how
high over that I I wouldn't know that
every again every night is different the
city pulls from different divisions if
there's special events going on so it's
constantly changing
okay
um but it's usually at least five and
maybe somewhere between five and ten if
there's not a special event would that
be a fair estimate
correct
what was the process for checking out
equipment in May 2016 after roll call
we would walk through the window and
give them our name and serial number and
they would present us with equipment for
the shift
and what
after roll call
I don't recall
you don't recall any of the equipment
you were you checked out in May of 2016
after roll call
I don't remember that specific day that
I checked out equipment I can tell you
what I typically check out if that's
what you'd like
all right let's start there
I usually check out a police vehicle
a taser
a less lethal beanbag shotgun
and a regular shotgun
no nothing else
a body worn video equipment
yes if you were trained and body worn
video then yes you would check that out
were you train and some body worn video
equipment
I was not
have you ever been assigned body worn
video equipment
yes I have
when
I don't remember the specific date
what's your best estimate
if I had to guess it would probably be
June of 2016.
why do you think it was June of 2016
that you first were assigned a
bugatti-worn video equipment
because that's the time frame that I
remember having to use it it was new to
me I never used buddy one before
did the LAPD start issuing body worn
equipment for Central Division
I don't know that date
went approximately
I don't know I couldn't give you a date
can you name any other officer that did
not have body-worn equipment that was on
your shift at any time between November
2015 and June 2016. other than you
I cannot
have you had more than one body worn
video equipment
body worn camera is that what you're
asking yes
I have had two
one in Central Division
and now a new one at Southwest Division
where I currently am the camera stays at
their respective divisions
while you were at Central Division did
you ever get assigned more than one body
worn video camera
not to my knowledge so to the best of
your knowledge you had the same body
worn video camera throughout the time
that you were at Central division is
that correct
correct
do you have a recollection of at any
time while you were at Central Division
your body worn video camera
not working so you couldn't turn it on
during an incident
I do not recall that what tools were
available to you in May of 2016 for
investigating calls answering an
investment
can you specify what you mean by tools
well did you have a notebook for example
yes we carry Phil officers notebooks
and did you have your own field officer
notebook
yes can you describe what your field
officer notebook looked like in May of
2016.
it's a small
just paper pad that we keep in our
pockets to write on
and do you carry a pencil or a pen with
it so that you can take them out during
a call and take notes
I do
what do you do with your notebooks once
you have filled them
you can turn them into the kit room and
they can store them
is that what you have done
I have
I have my same officers filled uh field
officers notebook in my locker
did you started
uh no I thought I've had several
different ones but I usually keep them
in my locker
so
for the field officer's notebook that
you had in May of 2016 that would be in
your locker
it should be yes
how many field officer notebooks have
you filled since you've been a police
officer
not many probably less than
less than five
and do you recall how many roughly how
many pages are in each field officer
notebook
I no I don't recall
did you have access to Dart
I don't I don't recall what hours they
worked at Central Division
what did Dart stand for
I don't know the specific acronym but I
know it's the domestic violence card
did you also have access to
report types of reports incident reports
various forms diagrams things of that
nature in case you needed them
yes I did
and where were where were those kept
when we were on a shift
I'm talking about May 2016.
I usually keep extra spare reports in my
bag and I also keep them in my vest
so when you answered calls in May of
2016 you had reports material in your
vest as you answered calls is that
correct yes
it's a deposition exhibit number 14.
it's multiple multiple page document I'm
just asking her if she recognizes this
document
yes I do
okay when is the last time you reviewed
this document
about a week ago
what were the circumstances under which
you reviewed this document a week ago
for this testimony
no
I asked you some questions about uh the
body worn video are you aware
of anyone
any other officer being assigned your
body worn video under your serial number
I'm not aware
is there any chance that you could be
mistaken about when you were assigned
body-worn video
no there's not
and why do you say that
because everything is recorded and
documented on evidence.com under my
serial number
so if a supervisor wanted to
enter the database under my serial
number they could watch my videos and
see the specific date and time
my videos started to record
and when the date of my last video was
to this date
uh all right and did you go back and
look to see what date you started
I did
what was the date that you were assigned
body worn video equipment in Central
Division
so the first day that I took out body
worn video was June 16th of 2016.
I'm going to show you this second page
of what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number one it has you summoned
to attend and give testimony the
deposition and also to produce certain
documents and do you recall did this
being issued
yes I do
and here we go the documents to be
produced
the first of those was all video footage
recorded by you relating to any incident
at 849 South Broadway Los Angeles
California
90014 on May 21 2016 including all video
footage relating to incident number and
it has the number on May 21 2016.
did you conduct any type of search or or
any kind of
effort to see if you had any video
footage on May 21 2016 relating to this
incident now the answer is no
ask you to take did the anyone at the
LAPD at any point supervisors watch
commanders commanders anyone connected
with the LAPD ever asked you whether you
had any video footage from the incident
of May 21 2016. no
I'm going to ask you to take a look at
number two here it says all documents
and or Communications including without
limitation any notes memoranda reports
filings and or summaries relating to any
incident at 849 South Broadway Los
Angeles California
90014 on May 21
2016. are you aware
of any documents or Communications
that would fit this description
no no
officer signs you've had training
correct
correct could you tell me what that
consists of
we received training in the police
academy
anywhere else did you have any other
type of domestic violence training other
than when you were in the place Academy
other than my experience in the field
during with domestic violence no not
that I can recall
May of 2016. would you agree that you
had answered over 100 domestic violence
calls
about Yahweh yeah I go to yes I go to a
lot of domestic violence bills every day
and
consider yourself to be a specialist in
domestic violence is that accurate
I don't I don't understand the title
specialist I don't
consider myself specialist
in May of 2016 what was the police
officer supposed to do when the victim
of a domestic violence would not respond
to questions or cooperate with pursuing
charges after a call was placed and the
police officers had arrived if an
individual is uncooperative
we are to check the location to make
sure that the suspect isn't hiding for
the safety of the
potential victim
and offer a business card if they decide
to speak to us later in May of 2016 was
it your understanding that if you saw
evidence of injury
property damage and disarray that you
were to file a report even if the victim
was not cooperating
correct
let me show you was remarked as exhibit
number eight and this is uh
something that was dated November 24
2018. it's to all Department Personnel
from the chief of police
domestic violence supplemental report
form
and it starts out with the domestic
violence supplement report form and it
has the number of it has been revised to
provide a more concise picture of the
history and needs of the victim for the
purpose of investigating the crime of
domestic violence was this a document
that you recall receiving at some point
yes okay and do you understand why do
you have any understanding of why this
was supplemented in November 24 2014.
how'd you know
I'm going to ask you officer to take a
look at what has been marked as exhibit
number nine and it's called Los Angeles
Police Department domestic violence
supplemental report do you recognize
this document yes okay and what is your
understanding of what this document is
it's a supplemental document that we
add to a police report for domestic
violence
and is this one of the reports that you
would carry in your vest when you
answered calls
yes
I'm going to ask you to take a look if
you if you can at the very left hand
column
where it has a number of different uh
categories here and it has victim
shaking unresponsive crying scared angry
fearful
being of why these are included on this
supplemental domestic violence report
so I identify somebody's emotional state
during an investigation
and this is specifically with respect to
domestic violence correct correct
okay and then if you can turn over to
the crime scene section on the right
hand side uh you'll notice that there
are some categories that include
location vandalized slash ransacked
personal property damage Furniture
disarray broken
um what is your understanding of why
those categories are included in there
for
making notations for domestic violence
supplemental report
to identify the crime scene at the time
of the incident
and was it your understanding that these
items that they have on here may be
significant in assisting and determining
whether there was in fact domestic
violence and improving and improving the
case
right
and direct your attention specifically
to the evidence section
and it indicates Witnesses present
during domestic violence
statements taken evidence collected
photos taken
[Music]
what is your understanding of the
significance of this and from collecting
this information
it's significant to tell a story about
what happened at the domestic violence
incident
okay
we can scroll down a little bit further
to additional questions there's a series
of those
including has suspect threatened to kill
you
did they possess new Firearms have they
ever attempted to smother a strangle or
suffocate you
and things of that nature what is your
understanding of why you're supposed to
ask those questions
give you a background on the
relationship an idea what the victim and
the suspect have been through
okay thank you just just let me ask you
the question officer science you did not
fill out that supplemental report when
you responded on May 16 2020 May 21 2016
to the Broadway
call correct with Amber Heard
correct it did not meet criteria
and the question I asked was did you
fill out one of those forms
no I didn't know I did not mean
I was excited I'm ready to ask you to
take a look at what has been marked as
exhibit number 10 and if I can direct
your attention to the top it says
domestic violence standards of review
and it has field notebook divide or
domestic violence laws LAPD form number
18.30.02 are you familiar with that
yes
it's it has a case preparation it says
note the complainants emotional and
physical condition do you see that
yes I do and then ensure all evidence is
gathered and preserved EG blooded
clothing damaged Foams property
you see that yes I do
and it also says ensure photographs are
taken of injuries or lack of injury to
complainant and accused and then suggest
both a day or two after what is your
understanding of the reasons for
collecting this evidence
foreign
there's a crime this is important to
prove that a crime was committed
and what do you mean by fruits of a
crime
if we're talking domestic violence
the location would be evident so if
there's
you know a house is a ransack and that
should be noted in the report that would
be considered evidence
all right then we're going to go to the
second page here
and it has ensure photographs are taken
of scene and damaged property EG broken
Furniture holes in wall damage phones
phone card evidence of alcohol
consumption General disarray do you see
that
yes I did and what is your understanding
of why that would be important
same thing proof of a crime
okay
and then it also says canvas location
and interview all Witnesses
including children fresh complaint
Witnesses neighbors and local law
enforcement
you see that
yes I do and what would be the reason
for canvassing the location and
interviewing all Witnesses
that would be further Evidence
and what is your understanding of what
fresh complaint means
I I wouldn't I couldn't tell you
okay
and then if we go down a little bit
further it also has complainant
questions and it has questions such as
length and nature of relationship but
also prior incidents of domestic
violence reported in unreported
and what form of violence or abuse has
taken do you see that yes I do and how
long what is your understanding of why
that would be important
because it gives us an idea on
background of the relationship
okay
and then we go to the next page
and we have a little bit more here uh we
have the
too far
and that says how long the abuse has
been occurring any logs or Diaries is
there a pattern of alcohol or substance
abuse what is your understanding of why
those would be relevant
again because it gives us background on
what we're dealing with what type of
relationship this is
[Music]
correct
okay and then we have identify the
person who first saw the complainted
after the incident and it says in
parentheses fresh complaint witness so
I'm kind of guessing that must be the
definition
um but why would it be important to
interview or identify the person who
first saw the complaint adapted the
incident
they probably have the best recollection
it also has identified the person with
whom the complainant first spoke about
the incident press complaint witness
what is your understanding of why that
would be important
same thing the best recollection
have what have neighbor seen or heard
why would that be important
because it would prove to us that there
was an incident if there was other
people with the same story as the victim
okay and then we also
have the witness observe how physical
injury occurred why would that be
important
because that would tell us that
there was a crime that somebody got
injured
statements by the complainted and or
accused after the incident why would
that be important
because we're getting our story from the
complaint so
what they say is everything with the
crime all right let's look at 12 for a
moment this is uh from this is exhibit
number 12. it's Office of the chief of
police April 9 2002.
domestic violence victims memo and it
says purpose the department is
legislatively mandated to provide
specific information to victims of
domestic violence crimes and then they
go in to describe that
um what is your understanding of well
let me go a little bit further because
I'm not trying to I'm going to try to
move through this a little bit quicker
so it says to mitigate this issue the
department has begun to use the victim
information notification every day Vine
pamphlet to accomplish not only the
domestic violence information required
requirements under Section 13701 of the
California Penal Code but also to
provide information regarding the Vine
Program
did you did you have a copy of that
pamphlet was that something that was
given to you
yes
was that something that you typically
provided then as it says you should to
victims of domestic violence yes
what is your understanding of why you
were to provide the pamphlet okay you
understand the question
yes because it it gives resources to the
victims domestic violent resources like
uh shelters and
uh phone numbers to provide help I'm
going to show you what has been marked
as exhibit number 11. do you recognize
this document
yes I do this is the one
okay when you say Vine is this the
pamphlet that was being referred to okay
and it's your understanding that you
were supposed to be giving that pamphlet
to victims of domestic violence on calls
is that cool right correct did you
provide a copy of this pamphlet to Amber
Heard
I did not I did not identify her as a
victim of domestic violence
is that the sole reason why you did not
give that to Amber
yes we want to give them to victims of
domestic violence I'm going to ask you
to take
at this point your honor uh Ms Hertz
council is asking to move into evidence
and publish to the jury defendants
exhibit 7 30 and Mr Depp has no
objection
okay
okay keep going
first page of exhibit number three it's
an incident recall uh from specifically
May 21st 2016. do you recognize this
document
yes I do
what please explain to me what what it
is
it's a summary of our radio call
all right and
how is this recorded
by Dispatch
and
how is it communicated to you
a computer in our card
so
I'm going to ask you to take a look at
the very beginning of this it start well
it starts out it obviously has an
incident number uh is this your
understanding of the incident recall for
the report to 849 South Broadway
involving Amber Heard
yes
it starts out with 5 21 16 at 20 30 58
which is 8 30 58 or almost 8 31 and it
says incident initiated by such and such
uh do you see that yes I do okay and the
next thing that's communicated is
Penthouse 3 PR received a call from
victim's friend Amber assaulted by
boyfriend PR refused to give further you
see that yes I do now when you were out
on the road did you see that right away
or did you have to look this up later
when it was you that was going to
respond
we review the calls as we're driving
through the to the call okay
then we have at 5 21
2037 which is 8 37 a duplicate call do
you see that I do all right let's go
down to
5216. officer signs can you go where I
just highlighted here
it's it's uh 2057 which would be what
time
8 57. all right and it has
sta-t colon as what does that mean
s
so would that be when you an officer
hadn't arrived at 849 South Broadway
correct
and then it has the next entry is 521
2016 it has 21
22 57 so that would be 922
okay
okay and it says go ahead I'll have you
read this what does it say after that
Matt with Vic
Chuck Loke
a verified husband Les loped
Vic advised verbal okay go ahead into
the next go ahead and go into the next
page or next line go ahead
dispute and refuse to give any further
info
issued
business card
who wrote those two lines I I don't
recall
and
what did that mean to you those two
lines that you just read
it's a it's a disposition of what
happened at the call
I mean what that means I mean just tell
me in real person's words what those
words are
yeah that we met with the victim we
checked the location uh the husband
wasn't there
and that the victim advises that she
just had an argument and that
she wasn't going to give us any further
information
and because we didn't identify crime we
issued her a business card
letting him know that she could reach
out to us later she changed her mind and
wanted to cooperate
okay and at what point did you close
this incident
uh whatever it says on the screen uh
let's see 9 22 57.
okay and what an incident closed mean
that we cleared from the location we're
a complete done
okay
now if we can go to page
the bait stamp number 12.
do you recognize this document
I do it's a summary of all of our calls
from that day
all right and I believe you testified
earlier that you reviewed this document
in preparation for this deposition is
that correct yes I did correct okay and
if we can go down to
right here
that's 922 correct at the end of that
right all right
it says
242d domestic violence what is that
it's a it's a code for domestic violence
and what is the 242 D mean that's
battery officer signs when we broke
before the lunch break I had just asked
you about whether you had believed that
you were at the penthouse on May 21st
2016 uh for 30 to 60 Minutes do you
recall me asking that yes I do and do
you recall testifying that that's what
you thought was the time that you an
officer hadn't spent at the penthouse on
yes I recall
and in fact it was significantly less
correct correct
okay and in fact it was a new entered
from the elevator at 904 pm and went
back into the elevator at 9 19. 15 total
minutes correct correct
and and we've seen the video clips of
you getting on the elevator and getting
off
um and that's where those time stamps
come from now once you got off the
elevator at 904 PM
the first thing you did was listen for
some noise correct
correct all right and then you went
around uh and checked out the outdoor
Courtyard to see if anyone was outside
do you recall that yes I do
and you saw that there was a woman in
the gym who was not related to the
incident do you recall that correct how
did you know the woman was not related
to the incident
because she seemed unfazed she was just
working out
did you speak with her no I didn't do
you recall what she looked like
I don't
now did you take any notes during the
entire 15 minutes from when you got off
the elevator till when you got back on
the elevator from the did not
did Officer Patton to your knowledge
not to my knowledge no okay did you uh
take pictures or record anything
I did not
so after you saw the woman in the gym
and and looked at the parameter you went
back to the holiday the hallway and you
met with what you called a white male
who was generic you recall using that
term
they asked me to describe him yes
you said generic New York correct
it didn't have any
identifying
uh
I don't know nothing that I could
remember he just I just remember a a
male white
nothing out of the ordinary
what color was his hair
I don't even remember now did he have
facial hair a beard or a mustache I
don't remember you would call how tall
he was roughly
I don't remember anything about him
did you ask him his name
I don't recall
now the generic white male talked with
you do you recall that yes I do and when
you first saw Amber Heard she was crying
red-eyed and was not making eye contact
with you correct correct
and you asked her a few questions and it
was quite clear that she did not want to
speak to the police is that correct
correct
now amberford was visibly upset
so she would look down sometimes she
would look up at you and she spoke but
was back and forth correct correct what
was Amber Heard wearing that night
I don't recall
well hairstyle did Amber Heard have that
night
I don't recall
no when was the first time you were
asked to provide details of the events
of May 21 2016.
I don't recall
do you recall providing your testimony
at a deposition in July of 2016.
right
is that the first time you were asked to
provide any details of what your
recollection was of the events of May 21
2016.
sure
and that was roughly two months later is
that correct
fact
and how many shifts had you worked in
that two-month period
uh I'm not aware I don't know how many
calls had you answered in those two
months
I don't know that number
how many of those calls were domestic
violence calls in those two months
I don't know that number
and
if you saw any signs of injury on Amber
Heard
or even just damage to property
would you have been Duty bound to make a
report
correct
now
your recollection is that there was no
damage to the the flat you search the
entire flat and there was no damage
broken glass or anything out of the
ordinary would you agree correct did you
see anything did You observe anything
out of the ordinary during this
particular call that you answered at the
penthouse on May 21 2016.
I did not when you left that call when
you got back into that elevator do you
recall what you were thinking
I remember being impressed by the the
penthouse how big and beautiful it was
yes
but anything else
no nothing
and just so we can stay on that for a
minute you did not you had not heard of
Amber Heard at the time of this report
right on May 21st 2016. correct
but you did know that Johnny Depp was an
actor correct correct
and you didn't know that that was Johnny
Depp's Penthouse and when you reported
there correct
but you as you just said were impressed
with the penthouse would it be fair to
say you thought probably somebody with
some wealth lived there correct can you
bring up planet's exhibit number 23.
officer signs do you recognize this
elevator at all
yes I do
what do you recall that's the elevator
from the location
uh Alex I'm going to ask you to go to
21
1940 and as you're moving that officer
signs I'm going to ask you to take a
look at this and see if you can tell me
what you are saying to officer Hadden in
this video clip
that's you is that correct and officer
hadn't do you recognize
officer sayings can you tell what you
were saying to officer hadn't I cannot
does it look like you might have said at
the beginning that was crazy
I can't tell what I was saying
would you agree though that you were
quite animated in your discussion with
officer Haddon
no I wouldn't agree
how would you describe your demeanor
comfortably talking to my partner
all right I'm going to ask you to take a
look at plaintiff's exhibit number 17
and while Alex is bringing that up so
your best recollection is that you saw
no injuries on Amber Heard correct
correct and your best recollection is
you said nothing no property damage
nothing in disarray nothing out of the
ordinary correct correct and if you had
seen either of those you would have had
to file a report correct
correct
officer signs let me ask you this
question so we've established that you
got off the elevator on the penthouse
level at 904 PM do you recall that
yes I do
um do you recognize the person here
yes I do Amber Heard
do you see any signs of injury on
Amber's herd's face in this picture
I do not
is it your testimony
that you do not perceive this cheat to
be reflecting an injury on Amber Heard
correct no injuries to take a look at
this section here above the eyelid and
now I think with the uh I'm gonna ask
you to take a look at that eyelid is it
your perception that that eyelid does
not reflect an injury
I'm sorry what was your answer
crap no injury okay and then up above on
the forehead level where the redness
isn't it looks like there's a couple of
bumps is it your perception that does
not reflect an injury correct officer
science I'm going to ask you to look at
what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number 18 close to the time that
you alighted from the elevator correct
please describe for me what you see in
this photograph
y
a striped carpet with discoloration on
the
right hand side of the photo and
what I perceive as I don't know if
that's a reflection
some sort of Mark
now you
believed and testified in fact that you
considered the hallways to be very well
lit that night correct correct did you
see this new stains
no not today
do you
do you
do you agree that there are those are
Reddish stains on the right side correct
what does it look like in you from your
experience
like a stain like from a like a liquid
red wine uh possibly it could be yes
okay
but you don't recall seeing that in the
hallway after you got off the elevator
I do not
and you did not investigate this or take
any pictures or record anything about it
correct
okay now let's go to number 19.
do you recognize what is depicted in
exhibit number 19.
yes it's our business card and it has
1a1 on the front of it what is that
that's our unit designation
and then it has Hadden and a badge
number is that his badge number
that is the serial number okay serial
number thank you and it has your name
and is that your serial number correct
who who wrote this on the card
I don't recall
would it have been either you or officer
hadn't correct you recognize your
handwriting
I I can't tell from this no I think you
indicated when you were looking at the
incident recall and had summary that a
business card had been left do you
recall that yes I do
why did you leave a business card
I advise uh Amber Heard that she could
contact us at any time if she changed
her mind and decided that she wanted to
speak to us and cooperate
all right let's go to number 20.
do you recognize this
what's predicted in this picture
yes I do it's the back of the business
card
all right and it says 5 21 2016 and the
time is 9 16 p.m is that the time that
the car that was written
correct okay and do you recognize the
handwriting on this side
it looks like my handwriting
it says radio call of dispute
dispute I do
um did did why didn't you put verbal
dispute
it didn't
verbal dispute dispute it's the same
it's the same thing to me
I've refused report on here correct
correct
could you just read that this next part
that you wrote on here
sure advice can call at later time it
changes mind because she was
uncooperative and didn't want to speak
to us
okay now why did you say if change is
mind
because I was giving her the opportunity
to have a resource if she changed her
mind
but if I ever heard had no injuries and
there was no evidence of any type of
physical
property issues uh disarray breakage Etc
then why would it matter if she changed
her mind
it's a courtesy that I I choose to give
people when I go to calls
now if Amber Heard had called you later
you had already closed this out and had
not written a report and had taken no
notes correct
but if I'm understanding your earlier
testimony that if you saw evidence of
injury or if you saw injury
evidence of property damage even if the
victim did not cooperate you would write
a report correct
correct
and we'll go to number 21 officer signs
this is just a picture do you recognize
you and officer Hadden here yes I do
okay Officer signs
is the time stamp on here of 9 19 p.m 49
p.m does that comport with your
recollection of when you left
I don't recall what time I left I'm just
going based on the video that is in
front of me
okay what do you have any reason to
believe that's incorrect
I don't
know obviously science I'm going to ask
you to take a look at exhibit number 24.
do you recognize the person in this
photo
yes Amber Heard
do you perceive
uh there to be an injury or evidence of
injury on Amber's face
in this phone
no I do not
uh
what is your uh perception of the
redness on the cheek and the eyelid and
above the eyebrow it's consistent
crying she's bare skin her face is blush
I'm going to ask you to look at one of
the Martinez exhibit number 25 do you
recognize this is Amber Heard yes I do
you see a red mark on Amber heard's
cheek and above her eyelid and above her
eyebrow on this picture
her face looks flush she has redness
and what is your perception of
what that is caused by
like I said earlier it's consistent with
what I see in her crying
but you don't think it's consistent with
a cell phone being thrown at her
correct it does not look like an injury
caused from a cell phone
and why not
because it's consistent with somebody
crying her face is flush this was taken
at on May 21st I'm going to ask you to
look at what has been about this exhibit
number 26 if it was do you recognize
this as emperor yes I do in fact I was
there science and do you see any redness
on Amber heard's cheek and above her
eyelid and
and we'll go with those I do and what is
your perception of what the cause of
those is those red marks
it's consisted with her crying her face
is flesh
and is it fair to say that you did not
believe that this reflects an injury
all right and and would it also be fair
to say that you would not consider it
sufficient to investigate further
whether it's an injury
there's nothing that would stop me from
investigating I would continue to ask
your questions
and it's up to the victim if they want
to cooperate
but just so that we were clear here even
if the victim doesn't cooperate if you
see signs of injury you still
to testify to this and believe yourself
Duty bone to write a report correct
yes but in your mind you don't perceive
this as to be reflective of an injury is
that correct correct
and I'm going to ask you to take a look
at exhibit number 27. again do you
recognize this as Amber Heard
yes okay and do you see redness on the
cheek of Amber Heard on this one
listen
all right and then you had testified on
a number of these other pictures and on
this one as well that this is consistent
with crying
do you see any redness on Amber's other
Jeep
yes I do
is it the same or or similar to the
redness on the cheek on the right cheek
based on this photo it looks
like one cheek is redder than the other
and but you also don't see any
swelling with that
correct and I'm going to ask you to take
a look at what has been marked as
exhibit number 28.
do you recognize this as Amber Heard
yes I
okay and do you see redness on the right
cheek and above the eye
yes I do
and is it your perception that this
reflects any type of or could reflect
any type of injury
no
why not
because my perception is it was
consistent with her crying
all right let's take this don't go to
29.
I'm going to ask you the same questions
do you recognize this as Amber Heard
yes and do you see any redness in the
right cheek and above the eyelid
yes okay and is it your perception that
these are not indicative of injury
yes
and and what is your reasoning
consistent with her crying let's take
this one down let's go to number 30.
now if you testified
earlier that you
thoroughly search the penthouse do you
recall that testimony yes I do
okay uh and Josh drew the gentleman that
you called the generic mail actually
took you through and escorted you
through the the penthouse and the series
of Penthouse is correct
Production Office of science did you or
did you not thoroughly search the
penthouses on May
21st 2016.
we did search the panels
and you use the term thoroughly did you
not
I don't recall
do you feel like you conducted a
thorough search of the penthouses that
night yes I did I did a sweep a little
location for the suspect
and when you're talking about a sweep of
a location did you go through every room
yes every room
okay and was there anyone escorting you
through those wounds
yes the same mail that
we were met with at the beginning of the
call
you called the generic mail correct
correct
you also testified a little earlier that
this was a very nice series of
penthouses right
yes did you interview
the woman that was sitting with Amber
Heard
I attempted to there are all parties
were uncooperative
what what did you say to the woman that
was witnessed misheard
I don't recall the exact word but I
introduced myself to everyone and asked
if they seen what happened or know what
happened
then they all refused to speak to me
did you ask for their names
I recall yes I did ask my names nobody
would give me
their names now that's a little unusual
isn't it
no it's not a lot of people don't like
us
well is it that they don't like you or
is it
potentially that they don't want to with
a domestic violence situation are
reluctant to press charges
every situation is different
based on my current experience where I
work it's usually that people do not
like us
do you have a a recollection of what the
woman who was with Amber Heard looks
like
no recollection
do you know what color hair she had
I had zero recollection so you don't
recall how old she was how tall she was
what her hairstyle was what she was
wearing anything about her
zero recollection
but somehow you're sure you tried to
interview her and she refused to answer
questions yes it's common practice I I
try to interview everyone during my
investigation
so did you pull out your notebook at any
time while you were in the penthouse
I didn't know I had nothing to write no
one would speak to me well how did you
know that when you started asking the
questions that they weren't going to
give an answer
because they just looked at me
but wouldn't you pull out your notebook
first and then ask the questions then
write down the answers as they're giving
them to you no I don't put anything in
my hands for officer safety issues until
I'm sure that I have something to learn
I'm sorry officer can you repeat your
answer
I don't put anything in my hands for
officer safety reasons if I'm not sure
what I'm gonna write I keep my hands
free when I ask the questions I got no
answers therefore I didn't
take out any notebooks or pens
did you have any reason to fear for your
safety at the time that you were talking
with them or hurt and the woman with her
I always pray for my safety a potential
suspect could have been in the house so
yes I
my God was not down if that's what
you're asking
what what did you do first did you look
at the throughout the house to ensure
that the person wasn't there or did you
ask the questions first and then look at
the house
I attempted to ask questions first
I can't just go into a house and start
checking it without asking questions
so what questions did you ask first
I don't recall specific questions
you recall any of your questions
I don't
you recall any of the answers that you
were given
I don't recall now we went through the
domestic violence supplemental report
and some of the guidelines for officers
on domestic violence do you recall that
the crime scene a number of the items
reflected location ransacked location
vandalized furniture and disarray
personal property damage do you remember
those being items as the checklist for
prop for crime scene for domestic
violence
as they pretend to be domestic violence
reports yes I do
no
with the two officers who answered the
second call to the townhouse that night
I did not did you ever communicate in
any manner with the two officers who
answered the second call Philip anthrops
I did not did you communicate through a
third party to the second set of
officers relating to the domestic
violence call in your determination I
did not
did you know the two officers
who responded to this technical
do you know who they are to this day
I do not
have you ever spoken to the other two
officers
about uh about the responding to this
call on May 21st 2016.
I have not
have you ever spoken with anyone else
about your response and their response
to this call on May 21st 2016.
I have not
and just so everybody's aware up until
now you've been listening to question
from questioning from Miss herds council
at this point I believe we're going to
shift over to questioning from Mr Depp's
Council
well I want you to focus on um the date
of the incident that we've been talking
about during this deposition
and that is uh May 21st 2016. I'll refer
to that is the date of the incident
we understand what I mean when I say
data the incident yes I do
so as of the date of the incident or how
long it had had you uh been a training
officer
since
I believe the end of November
of 2015.
between six to eight months yes prior to
the date of the incident for how long
had you been a training officer
uh four to six months
and uh as of the date of the incident
approximately how many
um
incidents of domestic violence
had you uh
come across I couldn't tell you I've
I mean I believe they said hundreds
yeah that's how I understood it from uh
testimonial but in previous depositions
of these so it's it's in the hundreds
yes
okay
now
when you uh
and you indicated that
you proceeded to the incident at Eastern
Columbia building
due to what you heard from dispatch is
that correct
sure
and your college you sit here today uh
what you were told from dispatch that
you were to the Eastern Columbia
building on the date of the incident
I don't have an independent recollection
you're as you figure today you were a
call that it had something to do
um
[Music]
with a dispute at that location
okay
and when you first arrived at the scene
of the incident what did you first do on
entering the building
we met with a security guard in the
lobby who
escorted us to the elevator
did you ask that security guard any
questions about
um
the building start to adjust the
security Guardian questions
not that I recall
is the security guard uh escort you up
to the penthouse
they gave us access through the elevator
I do not believe that
they came up to the penthouse with us I
believe they just accessed elevator
and when you arrived at the penthouse
and exited the elevator was it just you
and your partner Mr Hadden
officer Hadley yes
and what did you do next
we tried to listen for any kind of
sounds
of domestic violence we checked the
hallways we didn't observe anyone
went out to a courtyard didn't observe
anyone
and
based on what I was just reminded of
there was a woman in the gym who didn't
seem involved
was working out looked fine nothing out
of the ordinary
and then we responded
to a door in the hallway and I knocked
and was met by a male
okay open to that point of time from
exiting the elevator to Knocking on that
door did you see anything that indicated
a crime I did not
point where you knocked on that door
did you see you see or hear or witness
anything indicating that there had been
a domestic violence perpetrated I did
not
up until you knocked on that door did
you see anything uh with which you would
have considered out of the ordinary
I did not
and I guess what I'm asking is walking
from the elevator
to the gym and then to
the door that you knocked on
um
was that who got we were in the hallway
yes I was in the hallway
I'm doing that time period from accident
elevator through to knocking on the door
um was there anything in the hallway
that was unusual to you not that I
observed no
did you see any uh standings on the
floor
not that I recall
any vandalism in that area
no I did not
did you see any broken glass in that
area
I did not
okay
and upon knocking on the door what
happened next
door
I don't remember the exact questions and
conversation we had but
I remember asking
if they called for help and he said that
it was the neighbor and that show was
inside of his house
apartment
with his girlfriend
and I asked him if they could step out
and he told me to wait and he shut the
door
and we waited
we waited for them to exit
I don't remember how much time passed by
and they came out and that's when we
were met with his girlfriend and who I
know now is misheard
in the hallway
and up until that point in time did you
hear anything that led you to believe
that a crime had been committed I did
not
up until that point in time did you see
anything the major believe that a crime
had been committed I did not
did you hear anything that made you
believe that there had been an act of
domestic violence there I did not
to that point in time did you see
anything the major belief that there had
been an act of domestic violence there I
did not
okay
so you indicated that
um
after you knocked on the door you spoke
with
and he spoke with the gentleman is that
correct
okay
and you previously testified to someone
as a generic white male is that the same
person
yes so your previous testimony and when
you were referring to a generic white
male that's the person who who opened
the door when you first knocked on the
truck yes there was only one male at the
location besides my partner
and there was only one note if that for
the entire time you're at the location
yeah so in the hall you met with a
generic white nail
misheard and the generic white males
question is that right
it was just those three folks
correct
and you were there with uh your partner
officer had
correct
and how in the hallway how far were you
standing from this herd
uh
it was close probably
like
two to five feet
and at that time did you notice any
injuries on this herd
I did not
okay were you looking to see if she had
any injuries at that time yes I was
and
um
so you were looking to see if Miss heard
had any injuries and he determined that
she did not is that accurate correct
the lighting good enough in the hallways
for you to make that determination yes
the hallways was well lit
and at the time were you wearing any
sort of corrected lenses I was not
what
although you're not wearing corrective
lenses were you prescribed corrective
lenses at the time
no I have never worn glasses and I'm not
prescribed I have good vision
and at that time did you have good
vision
yes at the time you were observing
misheard did you have good vision yes I
did
and Did You observe any injuries at that
time
no
what did you
[Music]
not heard at that time if anything
I don't have a independent recollection
again it's been so long I
I don't remember specific questions
okay
now let me just back up a little bit
during the time period when you left the
elevator
and uh when Ms heard came onto the
hallway
at any time did the generic white male
tell you that they've been an act of
domestic violence no he did not
tell you anything that made you think
there may have may have been an act of
domestic violence
no he did not
didn't tell you anything that made you
believe that that uh the crime may have
been committed no he did not
and during that time period did you ask
him
um what had happened or what was
happening yes I did ask him and
he
just
refused to give me any information
okay so now fast forward to what we were
talking about with respect to uh you in
the hallway with a generic weight male
misheard and the generic white males
girlfriend
um after he observed her and saw no sign
of injury what did you do next
I advised her that
we would be conducting a protective
sleep
just to make sure that there was no one
else in the house
and she agreed
if her neighbors the male could
accompany us with the protective Suite
okay
well that's heard what happened
yes I did
and what was her response
no response she was uncooperative kind
of an officer signed at that time was Mr
cooperative
MRT was uncooperative
thank you
um and by uncooperative does that mean
that when you asked her a question she
wouldn't say a word she'd say something
that made you think she was not
cooperating she wouldn't say anything
but just to be clear and you would ask
questions and she wouldn't say anything
correct
okay
and what did you do at that point
after the protective sweep
I asked her again if she wanted to talk
to me if anything happened
again I don't remember the specific
questions that I asked her
but I asked her questions to establish
if there was some sort of crime
who was involved and again she wouldn't
give me any information I asked I
attempted to ask her friend
uh The Other Woman in the room right
even
us the males to weigh in the hallway so
we could just be us women in there so we
could talk privately maybe she felt more
comfortable that way
still the denied that there was any
crime they wouldn't answer
any specific questions
so I wrote a business card I advised her
she changed her mind that she could call
us at any time and we would respond to
help her out
so backing up a bit to the timing around
the hallway with the three of them and
you testified that this herd was
uncooperative
um and then you indicated you did a
sweep I want to start with from the
point of time in the hallway where she
was uncooperative
trans transitioning to the sweep how did
that occur did you ask her if you could
look at Independence how did this how
did you go from standing in the hallway
to conducting a sweep
I I don't recall
you know before you
before you swept the penthouses
um did you ask if you could enter the
penthouses yes I did
and who and what was the response
I
I can't remember if she gave me a
response or nodded her head I I can't
remember
um what you observed or heard from this
heard uh you took it that she was
permitting you to enter the penthouses
and look around is that accurate
okay
okay
um was it more than one penthouse
there was yes there was two
okay and this turn sweep we've been
using is that a technical police officer
term
what do you mean by conducting a sleep
protected sleep and we do so to make
sure that there's some other individuals
that maybe
victims that are hurt inside of the
location or suspects hiding consuming
themselves some officers
uh that would attack the victim after we
left the location so we go in to verify
that any potential suspects
are gone from the location for their
victim safety
thank you and you conducted a protective
sweep of two penthouses correct
correct what was your understanding of
who owned or lived in the first
Penthouse that you performed a
protective sleep on
it was my understanding that
Amber Heard
that it was her home again the the
gentleman directed us that's why he came
with us we wouldn't get lost
I see and during your protective sweep
during the first pen of the first
Penthouse
um
did anybody accompany you during the
entire sweep
Yes the mail the only male that was
there besides my partner
and your partner conducted to sleep with
you correct
and
as to the protective sweep of the first
penthouse did you
um go into every room at the penthouse
to my knowledge yes
and was your knowledge based on the
generic white male leading you around
correct was it your understanding that
you as your protective sweep
included you looking in every room in
the penthouse
correct during the protective sweep of
the first penthouse
did you
see anything
that
LED you to believe that a crime had been
committed I did not
during the protector's belief of the
first penthouse did you hear anything
that made you think the crime had been
committed I did not
during the first protective sweep did
you see anything that made you think
that an act of Defense domestic violence
had occurred I did not
during the protective sleep of the first
penthouse did you
hear or see anything
I'm sorry did you
ever understand anything that made you
believe an active domestic violence had
occurred
I did not
uh
protective sweep of the first penthouse
up until that point in time
from
we're actually going to elevator up
until that point in time did you hear or
see anything that made you believe that
a crime had been committed I did not
open to that point in time did you hear
or see anything that made you think an
act of domestic violence had occurred I
did not
no I want to ask you you testified that
you testified to you
um
viewing
misheard and not seeing any signs of
injury
did you
ever again after that first feeling
during the interviews and throughout the
entire investigation I'm constantly
scanning her and watching so I if I see
any other observations that would
indicate any injury or domestic violence
and did you see anything like that
and you can see did you see anything
like that during the end time during the
entire time period that you were on that
call and
yeah do you believe that you
um
had enough time
doing this herd to determine whether or
not she had sustained any injuries
yes I do
and you deter and to be determined that
she sustained any injuries
I determined that she did not sustain
any injuries
so other than the conversation you had
with her in the hallway when you first
got there did you have any other
conversations with Mr
I did inside of the inside of the lost
or Penthouse sorry
okay was that before or after the
protective sleep sweep
I believe those before and after
I attempted
okay how many conversations separate
conversations did you have with Mr
I don't recall
there's at least the one
one hallway
and there was one before or after the
protective Suite correct
sorry I missed that answer
correct
okay
and
during the second conversation you had
with her after the one in the hallway
how close were you to her
the same
two to five feet she was right in front
of me
we close enough to get a good view to
determine whether or not she had any
injuries yes I was
and during that second conversation did
you determine whether or not she had an
injury
I determined that she did not have any
injuries
at any point in time during the incident
during the date of the incident
did you come
she did not
during the protective swoop of the
penthouse
did you see anything in disarray I did
not
okay
now you indicated let me ask you did you
do a protective sweep of the second
penthouse yes I did
and uh the generic white male
accompanying you accompany you on that
this week as well
yes he did
what was your understanding of who owned
or resided in that second penthouse
I had no idea
okay
did you during that second protective
Suite
did you walk through every room in that
penthouse
from my understanding yes we did
and during that second protective sweep
did you see anything that you would say
was in disarray
I did not
during that so I can protective sweep
could you see anything that made you
believe there had been a crime committed
I did not
bring that second protective sweep did
you hear anything that made you think a
crime that didn't commit I did not
during your protected sweep of the
second penthouse
did you see anything that made you
believe an act of domestic and violence
had occurred I did not
during the protected sweep of the second
set second penthouse did you hear or say
anything
that made you believe a crime had been
committed I did not
after you've performed the second
protective I'm sorry after you perform
the protective Suite sweep of the second
Penthouse what did you do
I re-responded to where Amber Heard was
and I again tried to see if I could get
any information from her
I was unsuccessful and then I issued her
the business card
and let her know that she could call us
back if she wanted to talk
did she answer any of your questions
no she did not
at any point in time during the entirety
of the incident could misheard answer
any of your questions no she did not
during the entire time of the incident
did miss her complaint of any injuries
no she did not
during the entirety of your time at the
incident
did anybody say anything that made you
believe a crime had been committed
no they did not
during the entirety of the time you were
at the incident did anybody say anything
that made you believe an active an act
of domestic violence had occurred no
they did not
during the entirety of your time at the
incident did you see anything that made
you believe a crime had occurred I did
not
during the during the entirety of your
time at the incident did you hear
anything the major believes a crime had
been committed
I did not
figure time
time did you hear or see anything that
made you believe that acted an act of
domestic violence had occurred I did not
had you heard of
anybody by the name of Miss heard at
that time
never
heard
no I have never heard of Amber Heard
before that time okay
did you recognize any of the people that
you encountered during the incident
I did not
the internet did you have any reason to
believe that anybody you encountered at
the incident uh
was famous
I did not
and during the entire time
so you're at the penthouses during the
incident
did you have any reason to believe that
Mr Jeff was affiliated
are involved
in the incident
I did not
a Madam reporter can you uh repeat my
last question in the last uh where I was
a question during during the entire time
you were at the penthouses during the
incident did you witness any bruises on
this herd
and there was not a response
observe any injuries on this Earth
Did You observe any swelling on a
certain state I did not
to observe anything
that led you to believe
that she was a victim of domestic
violence yes I did not Alex if you can
pull up a exhibit too
foreign
[Music]
uh yeah
officer signs we recall having your
having your deposition taken on July 18
2016 in connection with
um Mr death and misheard yes
okay
um
and you recall excuse me testimonial
connection with that deposition under
Oak
yes
and did you give accurate and true
testimony at that time yes
okay
and you understood you were under
correct correct
Alex if you can go to page 26.
officer signs do recall testifying as to
um
protocol testifying that and I'm talking
about today
Miracle just starts to find that
you
can recall what yes heard said to you if
anything I did not have an independent
recollection but I can go off what I'm
seeing here on my screen
uh your honor we're at five o'clock it
looks like we have about
18 minutes left do you want to you don't
have any problem finishing it tonight
dude let's go and finish it okay thank
you
and do you agree with me that your
memory of the day of the incident was
pressure on July 18 2016 than it is
today
yes that is correct
and
it was May 21st 2016. this deposition
was taken July 18 2016.
how long after the incident was this
deposition taken
uh a few months
okay
and
Alex if I could have control
a little delayed out to the canopy
fixture is that just the way it is
uh this is Alex speaking uh yeah I'm
afraid I can't uh help that I'm sorry Mr
President
yes I do
okay I'm gonna start here at line three
the question is
okay but we'll get back to that
before you did a a sweep or a check for
the rest of the penthouse
could you have an opportunity to speak
with Miss heard when you were in your
apartment answer yes I did
okay question okay can you tell us about
that conversation answer sure I asked
her what happened
in question she said nothing and she
continued to cry I said who do you live
with could you live here with she shook
her head as if she did not want to
answer
I asked her are you hurt
do you need an ambulance
and she shook her head again no
at that point I asked her if she mind if
she would mind if I checked her
apartment and that's when she said no
officer does this refresh your
recollection of the conversation you had
with Miss heard at that time yes it does
and your testimony that I just read is
that true and accurate yes it is during
the entire time period you were at the
penthouses
um
on May 21st 2016.
did Miss herd say that she had been
assaulted in any way like anybody
no she did not
foreign
your protective sweep of the two
penthouses
did you do anything that you would
characterize as vandalism
I did not
during the entire time you were at the
penthouses on May 21st 2016.
were you looking for any probable cause
to believe that a crime had been
committed
yes I was
and where did you determine
I determined there was no crime
did you what did you determine with
respect to an assessment of probable
cause
there was no probable cause of any sort
of crime
thank you
foreign
foreign
the entire time
you were at the penthouse on May 21st
2016.
wearing any body worn video cameras I
was not
are you certain about it
I am searching
and how are you how is it that you are
certain of that
because I didn't start using body worms
video until
June of 2016.
and that's after the date of the
incident correct correct
I'll accept you would mind putting
exhibit 9 back up
foreign
[Music]
it is a domestic violence supplemental
report
and we recall uh Council asked you about
the victim column and the crime scene
column
yes I do recall
um do you also see that there's a
suspect calling in the middle
yes
okay
and is there any difference between a
victim column and a suspect column with
respect to uh the terms and the terms
um the Box terms
no difference
did you throw out one of these forms in
connection with your investigation on
May 21st 2016.
I did not
why not
because it was determined there was no
crime
and officer signed just uh one more
question with respect to that exhibit
nine I know it's not up
but the
the fact that you did not throw out that
form uh
is that
um
consistent with your training yes it is
I wouldn't fill that out because there
was no crime it doesn't
it's not called for when he testified uh
during the London trial
uh
at the time did you believe your
testimony was accurate yes I do
um
I'm just testified
um
under oath in any legal proceedings
trials depositions
uh do you always give accurate and
truthful testimony yes I do
and do you have any reason to not give
accurate and trivial testimony
in connection with about this deposition
I do not
after it's time to see these two
pictures
yes I do
um do you recognize the person in the
pictures
yes Amber Heard
in both pictures
yes
you see a difference between these two
pictures
yes I I do the lighting
of the photos
do you see any difference in connection
with uh
the redneck on the Chiefs of this herd
as between these two patients yes I do
the the left side is
the photo's brighter
and other than that would you agree with
me that
these two pictures
are the same in other words
the search case
the position of her face everything
about
um
her in these pictures it is identical
except for the differences that you've
indicated yes
and even though these are the same
pictures can you see any difference with
respect to the redness
um
in
on this word space with respect to the
two patients it's the photo on the left
is brighter causing the redness on the
cheeks to
what appears to be brighter or
exaggerated
back to
which on the left
can you read for me what it says in the
little box
at the very top on the left
um
under add a title you see a date and a
time stamp
yes I see it
what's it say date and time stamp
date is May 21st 2016.
timestamp is 9 25 12 P.M
and now let's look at the other picture
exhibit 29 at the same spot can you read
for me that what the time stamp says
there
yes it says uh May 21st 2016 9 25 12 P.M
the boss exhibits both pictures are the
same exact time stamp correct
if that's the case do you still believe
that there's a difference between the
two pictures as you previously described
yes I do
three times the issues over 41.
yes
do you recall Council asking a question
yes
during your
protective sweep of the two pence houses
on May 21st 2016.
did you see anything in this array
no
popular uh signs
I think after this but up until up until
the present for how long have you been a
L.A Los Angeles police officer
I will be going on 12 years
science uh
in connection with your investigation uh
at the Eastern Columbia building on May
21st 2016.
uh were you in a Russian anyway yeah
investigation no
we're going to stay as long as necessary
to determine if a crime had been
committed yes
at any point in time during your
investigation on May 21st 2016 at the
penthouses did Miss heard ask you to
file a report
no
did anybody that you spoke with or saw
on May 21st 2016 at the penthouses ask
you to follow the court no
did you have any cause to file a report
no
and with that determination in line with
your training yes
if you had witnessed anything it led you
to believe that an act of domestic
violence had occurred would you have
failed to report yes
and you in fact did not file a report
correct yes
correct and
if you had witnessed something that led
you to believe and enact domestic
violence had occurred
um
would you have filed the reports even if
Miss work had asked you not to yes
is that in line with your training
yes
officer signs you were asked some
questions
and just so everybody's on the same page
we have about a minute and a half of
questions from Miss Hertz council at
this point
of the elevator in the penthouse and
when you got on and how much time you
spent at the penthouse level I
approached it in my earlier but based on
the cross-examination I feel like we
need to go back to that um so I'm going
to ask you to take a look at what is
exhibit number six and you recognize
that you and officer hadn't in this
picture
yes okay and what time does the time
stamp on this picture say for the
elevator
it says 2104 43. okay that's 904.43
would that be right p.m yes and we
looked at this earlier I'm going to ask
you to take a look at it again at 21 and
so this one has what time
21
1949 all right and allowing for in
Europe and officer signs you said
earlier that you weren't sure whether
there were accuracies or inaccuracies in
terms of the elevators but allowing for
that there may be any issues at all
would you agree that it still means that
you were on and off that elevator in 15
minutes
assuming that times are correct yes
asked to look at a number of the
pictures that I had shown you earlier
that were taken on the night of May 21st
2016 both before during and after the
time that you and officer hadn't had
reported to the
to Ms Herb's Penthouse do you recall see
those again and being asked about them
yes you were asked
by Council for Mr debb to take a look at
those again correct
correct okay and he asked you if you had
seen any of those photographs before and
you indicated that you had not correct
correct so
other than what was placed in the cad
summary by either you or officer Hatton
and then also went into the incident
recall
do you are you aware of any
documentation that either you or officer
hadn't collected relating in any manner
to your visit to the penthouse on May 21
2016.
no
all right thank you all right ladies and
gentlemen that includes uh the testimony
for today please do not do any outside
research and don't talk to anybody about
the case and we'll see you tomorrow
morning okay thank you
all right I uh I still have some
outstanding exhibits so if you could get
with Jamie and see which ones those are
so we can get that taken care of so we
don't get backwards and keep keep up all
right all right we'll see you in the
morning all right thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]